[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שלום, צהריים טובים. תוכלו לתת לי אינדיקציה אם שומעים אותי? כן, שומעים אותך. תודה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טוב, שלום לכולם. אנחנו נתחיל עוד איזה דקה. מי מכם שיכול לפתוח מצלמה זה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נראה לי יהיה יותר נעים לכולם. אני יודע שלא כולם יכולים, אבל מי שכן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי. אז אנחנו באופן עקרוני כיתה הרבה יותר גדולה. רגע, אני רואה שמישהו שלח הודעה כאן. אנחנו בדרך כלל כיתה הרבה יותר גדולה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני מקווה שתהיה לנו הזדמנות להתרשם מזה, זה קורס של מעל 200 תלמידים. אבל כן, אני מניח שרבים לא יכלו להגיע. אז טוב, ברוכים הבאים לסמסטר ב'.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שמי עומרי, עומרי אבנד. אני מניח שזאת לא הדרך שדמיינו את תחילת הסמסטר ולצערנו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יותר מדי מהסמסטרים שלכם בתואר התחילו בצורה לא מוצלחת. זהו, אז למרות זאת אנחנו ננסה להפיק מהשבוע הזה מה שניתן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ננסה לא להכביד עליכם יותר מדי, אבל בכל זאת כן כבר להתחיל ללמוד ולפחות לקבל רקע לקורס.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם לשחרר תרגיל אבל הוא לא יהיה למיד אחרי פסח, כך שמי שבתקופה הזאת פחות פנוי יוכל גם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לעבוד עליו אחר כך, אבל מי שכן מחפש הזדמנות טיפה להכיר את המושגים ולתרגל, אז תוכלו גם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז זהו, לטובת אלה ש... אז כמה אנחנו כאן? 35, אוקיי. אז לטובת מי שהצטרף עכשיו, ברוכים הבאים, שמי עומרי. אם תוכלו לפתוח את המצלמה, אני אודה לכם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני יודע שלא כולם יכולים, אבל בכל זאת נראה לי זה גם מצידכם מגדיל את ההשתתפות האקטיבית בשיעור וגם מבחינתי זה יותר נעים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אחרת זה קצת בקשר של שיעור מוקלט. בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תרגישו בנוח, אני רואה שכל עוד אנחנו במספרים האלה של תלמידים, אז פשוט אתם יכולים להרגיש בנוח לעצור אותי באמצע. אני מניח ש... אם באיזשהו שלב נהפוך ל...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: קבוצה הרבה יותר גדולה אולי נשנה, אבל לפחות כרגע אין שום בעיה, תעצרו אותי באמצע ותשאלו מה שעל ליבכם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טוב, בנוסף לטובת התלמידים המוסלמים, אני לא יודע אם מגיעים, אני מניח שרוב, רוב התלמידים המוסלמים חוגגים היום את עיד אלפיטר, אז אני מאחל לכם חג שמח.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ומצפה לראות אתכם אחרי החג ואחרי בסוף בשיעור הבא. טוב, אז אם ככה נתחיל בהקדמה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הקורס הזה כידוע לכם עוסק בעיבוד שפה טבעית, שהוא גם תחום העיסוק שלי כחוקר, ובאמת זאת זכות עבורי ללמד את קורס היסוד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בתחום הזה ולשתף אתכם גם מקורות התחום וההישגים שלו עד כה, וגם מההשקפה האישית שלי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בכלל על התחום ועל ההישגים וההתפתחויות הטכנולוגיות המואצות שאנחנו חווים בתקופה האחרונה. אבל לפני הכול,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בוא נתחיל בקצת מנהלות. אז אגב, כולם שומעים אותי טוב? כולם רואים אותי בסדר? אוקיי, אחלה. טוב, אז יש לנו תיבת אימייל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: צריך לוודא שהיא כבר עובדת, אבל אם לא, אז תעבוד מיד. תיבת אימייל, אז בבקשה תשלחו את המיילים שלכם בנוגע לקורס, חוץ מדברים אישיים שאתם לא רוצים לשתף אף אחד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חוץ מנגיד אותי, רגישים, בסדר. אבל נגיד אני מוציא את הסיפורים האלה, כל המיילים היותר יומיומיים בנוגע לקורס, אנא שילכו לתיבה הזאת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סגל הקורס בעצם מורכב ממני, שאני עומרי, אני חבר סגל בחוג למדעי המחשב וגם בחוג למדעי הקוגניציה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכן הייתי ראש החוג בקוגניציה עד לפני כמה חודשים, אולי חלקכם מכירים אותי משם, אני היום אחראי לאינטגרציה של אייאיי באוניברסיטה בכובעי השני, אז...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, יש לי גם את הפרספקטיבה הזאת, ותחום המחקר שלי הוא עיבוד שפה טבעית, אז ככה התאמה טבעית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הצער של הקורס ומי שאחראי על התרגילים באופן כללי, כולל מענה על שאלות בנוגע לתרגילים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כולל ערעורים על התרגילים, בדיקה וכדומה. זה איתן וגנר, שלא איתנו כאן היום, אבל אתם תפגשו אותו בהמשך. דוקטורנט אצלי במעבדה, ואתם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וזה המייל שלו כאן, אם יש לכם דברים יותר אישיים שאתם רוצים לפנות אליו, אז אתם מוזמנים. ואנחנו נפרסם את שעות הקבלה במודל, ברגע שקצת נחזור לפעילות יותר נורמלית, אבל אם אתם צריכים אותנו עוד קודם לכן,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לשעת קבלה, אז אני אשמח לקבוע איתכם באופן פרטני, אז תשלחו מייל אליי, לאיתן, לתיבת המייל, ונוכל להיפגש לשעת קבלה. בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לגבי הנהלים, אז ככה, הציון הוא יהיה מורכב מתרגילים ונבחר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מבחן כיתה. אז התרגילים הם 30 אחוז מהציון, יהיו חמישה תרגילים ויהיו תרגילים תיאורטיים ויהיו תרגילים מעשיים, תרגילי תכנות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ההגשות יעשו בזוגות. אם אין לכם, אם אתם לא מצליחים למצוא בן, בת, זוג, אז אתם מוזמנים לפנות אלינו שננסה לסייע בנושא.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מלבד זאת, יש מבחן בסוף הקורס, אתם מוזמנים ואנחנו גם נעלה לאתר בהמשך להסתכל על ה... אם מעניין אתכם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: על מבנה המבחן משנים קודמות, הוא יהיה דומה. לעיתים החומר מעט משתנה, יורד פרק, נוסף פרק, ואנחנו נבהיר את זה בהמשך, אבל בגדול מבנה המבחן נשאר די עקבי לאורך השנים, אז אפשר להבין ממנו.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בערך איזה סוג שאלות שואלים. אני לא דורש, אני גם לא אדרוש בהמשך הסמסטר נוכחות, אבל אני בהחלט
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ממליץ לנכוח בכיתה, אני יודע שיש אנשים שמעדיפים ללמוד לבד, אבל מניסיוני זה מתאים למיעוט התלמידים. עכשיו, יכול להיות שאתם נמנים על המיעוט הזה, ואז מה שאני אומר עכשיו לא רלוונטי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל אני סומך עליכם שבשנה ג' או אולי חלקכם כבר יותר מזה, אתם כבר יודעים מה מתאים לכם ואם אתם מפיקים, אם אתם חלק מהרוב שמפיק,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מגם לשמוע דברים בעל פה, אני מאוד ממליץ להגיע, אני חושב שיש לזה ערך מוסף. אבל אתם לא חייבים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לגבי מילואימניקים, אנחנו יודעים שיש תלמידים שנמצאים במילואים, חלקם און אנד דוף,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כבר שנתיים וחצי, חלקם גויסו לסבב הזה, חלקם עוד יגויסו אולי ויחזרו, אז ברור שזה יוצר קושי דרמטי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: על המשרתים ואנחנו ערוכים לכך. אז יש דבר ראשון הנחיות באתר, כל מיני נהלים מיוחדים שנוגעים למילואימניקים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מאוד חשוב לי שאם הייתם במילואים ארוכים ועכשיו חזרתם, אתם לא, אני אומר את זה גם לטובת כמובן מי שלא כאן ויצפה בהקלטה, עכשיו חזרתם,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אתם לא בדיוק יודעים מה קורה, יש לכם המון קורסים להשלים, לא בדיוק ברור. אנא, צרו קשר עם איתן, הוא ירכז את הנושא הזה, הוא יעבור איתכם על תוכנית הקורס, ננסה להבין מה לפתור אתכם, מה להשלים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואיך להיערך. אז ככה מלבד הנהלים היבשים, אנא פנו אלינו אם חזרתם עכשיו מאיזושהי תקופה ומתחילים להשמיע. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טבעי בקורס הזה גם לדבר קצת על כלי איי ואיך הם משפיעים על... בכלל על למידה והוראה. אז אולי אני אגיד ככה בצורה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בצורה כללית, שאין לנו עדיין תשובה לזה. כי אוניברסיטה ולמעשה גם אוניברסיטאות אחרות וגם המובילות בתחום, אין להם עדיין תשובה מה זה אומר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לדעת לכתוב בעידן האייאיי, מה זה אומר לדעת לקרוא בעידן האייאיי, כאילו לקרוא מאמרים אני מתכוון, או טקסטבוקס וכאלה בעידן האייאיי, מה זה אומר לתכנת בעידן האייאיי. יש לנו כבר מושגים מסוימים, אבל...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אתם בטח כבר רואים בעצמכם, השינויים הם מאוד מהירים וכן, זה לא פשוט להיערך. בכל זאת, יש לי כאן כמה הנחיות שאני נותן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שיהיו תקפות לצורך הקורס הזה, ואני חושב אולי לפחות יוכלו לתת לנו מענה מסוים לאתגרים שהנושא הזה מעלה. זה אתגרים מגוונים, נכון? זה יוצר א',
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אתגרים להבין מה עדיין חשוב או מה אולי אפילו נהיה יותר חשוב, נדבר על זה קצת בהמשך, לאור
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: קיומם של קודינג אסיסטנס ורייטינג אסיסטנס ורידינג אסיסטנס, כן? אז מה נהיה יותר חשוב? מה נהיה פחות חשוב? האם המיומנויות שנדמות כפחות חשובות הן בכל זאת מיומנויות?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שראוי להקנות לבוגרים במדעי המחשב או לתלמידים שסיימו קורס בעיבוד שפה טבעית, סך הכול אתם לא משתמשים, אתם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: משהו יותר מזה, כן? התקווה אחרי שאתם יוצאים עם תואר מהאוניברסיטה העברית. זה מעלה שאלות לגבי הערכה, איך ניתן להעריך תרגילים בצורה מהימנה, נכון?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולהימנע מזה שבעצם מגישים תרגילים שאנחנו בעצמנו לא לגמרי יודעים מה כתוב שם ושלא התחככנו עם החומר מספיק כדי לפתור אותם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, זה מעלה גם שאלות שיותר נוגעות, אני חושב פחות נעסוק בזה, אבל כמובן שהתחום גם משפיע על הצורה שבה מלמדים קורסים, ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני מקווה שיהיה לי פנאי במהלך הקורס גם להטמיע קצת כלי איי שיסייעו לכם ללמוד ולא רק לפתור את התרגילים. אני מתכוון ללמוד תוך כדי השיעורים או בבית בעצמכם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל זה באמת כל הסמסטר הזה הוא כולו קצת כאוטי בינתיים, אז אני לא אגיד משהו יותר דפיניטיבי. טוב, ועכשיו לנהלים. לגבי ככה הנהלים, אז בגדול מותר לכם להשתמש.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מותר לכם להשתמש בכלים, איזה כלים שאתם רוצים, אבל יש כאן כמה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמה הנחיות מחייבות. דבר ראשון, עם כל הגשה אתם צריכים להסביר, כלומר לכתוב באיזה כלים השתמשתם ולמה, זאת אומרת לשם מה השתמשתם בהם, לאיזה מטרות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זאת הוראה מחייבת. זאת אומרת, זאת לא המלצה, זאת הוראה מחייבת. כן, זה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זאת אומרת, אני לא יודע איך בדיוק אני אוכל לבדוק את זה, אבל ככל שצוות הקורס יגיע למסקנה שמישהו דיווח דיווח שקרי, אז זה כמובן עבירת משמעת, אני לא יודע איך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בדיוק נדע את זה, אבל מה שאני מתכוון לומר כאן, זה שזה משהו שאנחנו בהחלט מתייחסים אליו ברצינות. הסיבה לזה היא שאני חושב שדיווח כזה עוזר לנו גם לעשות רפלקציה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לגבי מה למדנו, מה לא למדנו, איזה חלקים אולי רפרפנו עליהם ואנחנו לא לגמרי יודעים להסביר מה נעשה שם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וזה מוביל אותי לנקודה הבאה, אתם ורק אתם, כלומר המגישים, אחראים לתוכן של התרגיל. כלומר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם מופיע שם, אם מופיעות שם טעויות, אז אתם תאבדו נקודות עליהם, גם אם אלה טעויות שנעשו תוך שימוש סביר בכלים האלה, כן? זאת אומרת, שוב, אני...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בהחלט מציע למי שמעדיף, מי שלומד בצורה יותר אפקטיבית להשתמש בכלים שאתם משתמשים בהם, אבל אתם צריכים לקחת בחשבון שאתם אחראים על מה שאתם מגישים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מעבר לזה, אני רואה שהמשפט שלי איכשהו כתבתי אותו באמצע, כתבתי לעצמי שספציפית אנחנו נוריד נקודות ולעיתים הרבה נקודות, אם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יוגשו לנו מה שנקרא תרגילים מרושלים, כן? כלומר, תרגילים שיש בהם טעויות כל כך ברורות, כנראה כתוצאה מהשימוש באייאיי, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו לא יודעים. כל מיני שהם נראים כאילו לא עברו עליהם ולא בדקו אותם בצורה מספקת, כן? שיש בהם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טעויות מביכות כאלה, כן? או דברים שמעבר סיסטמטי ומעמיק היה פשוט, מגלה. אוקיי? אז קחו את הדברים האלה בחשבון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובהחלט אפשר לדון בזה בהמשך הסמסטר, או אולי עכשיו אתם רוצים להעיר משהו לגבי זה. וכן, חשוב להיזהר לא לעשות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שאוהבים לקרוא בזמן האחרון קוגניטיב אוף לורדינג. כלומר, הנה יש לי בעיה, אני לא יודע איך לפתור אותה, אבל אני פשוט אתן למערכות האלה לעשות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: את התרגיל במקומי, בלי שבעצם יש כל כך מושג מה עושים שם. א', זה פרקטיקה לא טובה, זה לא טוב לכם כחלק מההכשרה שלכם לעשות את זה, כן? זה ברור.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ומעבר לזה, באופן מאוד פרקטי, זה עשוי להתנקם בכם כשתגיעו למבחן, כן? פשוט לא תכירו את החומר בצורה מספיק טובה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הבעיות הן ברורות. אז מכיוון שאני יודע שזה נושא מורכב וטעון, אז אני אשמח אם מישהו מכם רוצה להעיר הערות בקשר לזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי? מקבלים את הדין, אני מבין. אוקיי, טוב, בסדר. אחלה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר, לפני שנצלול לחומר הקורס, רציתי לשאול שתי שאלות מנהלתיות נוספות. א',
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: האם אתם יודעים או מונה מישהו שייצג את הקורס מול הסגל? נציג... שכחתי איך קוראים לזה, נציג האגודה, נציג הוועד, נציג ה... יש...
Maya Kurland: ידוע לכם על זה? על כל פנים... אין כרגע נציג לקורס, אין מישהו שהתנדב לייצג אותו כרגע. אה, הבנתי. אוקיי, אז ככל שיהיה, אני אשמח אם באמת אותו... כן, אותה תלמידה או אותו תלמיד יצרו איתי קשר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה נראה לי טוב שיהיה, בטח בסמסטר כל כך מורכב. שאלה מנהלתית אחרונה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: האם אתם חושבים שזה יסייע לכם שתהיה קבוצת וואטסאפ להודעות של הקורס או שהודעות במודל בפורום זה מספיק טוב לכם ואתם פשוט קוראים את האימייל וזה בסדר?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מישהו מוצא בזה ערך? מישהי? לא? רגע, אולי כתבו בצ'אט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עדיף אסף, עדיף מה? עדיף הוואטסאפ או עדיף המייל? וואטסאפ. אוקיי, בסדר. אז בקיצור,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נראה שלפחות חלק מהסטודנטים אוהבים את הוואטסאפ, אז אנחנו נפתח קבוצה ואם אתם רוצים תרשמו אליה, ואם לא אז לא. זה בכל מקרה תהיה קבוצה רק של הודעות שלנו, אז זה לא משהו שאמור להכביד לכם על ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, על הווטיפיקיישנס. טוב, שאלות נוספות בקשר למה שהעליתי כאן לפני שנעבור לחומר עצמו?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, נהדר, אז נתחיל. אוקיי, מה זה איבוד שפה טבעית? אז דבר ראשון, חשוב לי לציין שזה תחום שיש לו בעצם שתי פרספקטיבות משלימות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שלעיתים התבוננות מכל אחת מהפרספקטיבות האלה עשויה להוליד תשובה שונה לאותן השאלות, אוקיי?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו בעיקר נעסוק בפרספקטיבה אחת, אבל אנחנו פה ושם ניגע גם בשנייה. אני מתעניין בשתיהן. אז אחת מהן היא הכיוון האפליקטיבי או הכיוון הטכנולוגי, כן? בעצם זה מדבר על עיבוד שפה טבעית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כתחום שעוסק בטכנולוגיה לעיבוד שפה, סליחה, לעיבוד שפה, בשנים האחרונות גם מאוד עלה גנרציה, בייחוד של טקסט, אבל לפעמים גם של קול.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, כלומר יצירת טקסטים, וזאת פרספקטיבה אחת. פרספקטיבה טכנולוגית, פרספקטיבה יישומית. הפרספקטיבה השנייה היא הפרספקטיבה של מדע בסיסי. אז בעצם,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הפרספקטיבה הזאת חושבת על התחום כתחום שעוסק
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: במודלים חישוביים שמנסים לתפוס איזשהו יכולת אנושית מסוימת, מנסים למדל יכולת אנושית שפתית, התנהגות אנושית שפתית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ויש יגידו אפילו שממש מנסים לתפוס אינטליגנציה אנושית, כן? וזאת, אתם ודאי שמעתם, אני מניח, בשלב הזה של התואר על מבחן טיורינג, למשל, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון? מבחן טיורינג שבעצם מגדיר אינטליגנציה, לא יכולת שפתית, אינטליגנציה, נכון? אלן טיורינג הגדיר באופן כללי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כבעצם יכולת שפתית שהיא בלתי ניתנת להבחנה, כן? אינדיסטינגושבל, מזאת של בן אדם. אז בהחלט...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם הדיון כאן הוא יותר רחב וגם בזה ניגע קצת. מטבע הדברים, בקורס במדעי המחשב, הפרספקטיבה שלנו תהיה יותר אלגוריתמית, יותר טכנולוגית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני מעביר גם קורס בקוגניציה שאני רואה שחלקכם לפחות, או אחד אני רואה כאן בינתיים, שלקח.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז שם אני מדבר יותר על הכיוון הקוגניטיבי, אז זה יכול להיות איזשהו קורס משלים למי שמתעניין. טוב, אז אני התחלתי ללמד את הקורס הזה בשנת 2000 ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: 16, כן? לפני עשור. ואז הייתי צריך, היו בהחלט תלמידים שהיו מגיעים לקורס, נרשמים לקורס, היה נשמע להם מעניין, אבל הם מעולם לא השתמשו
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ושאולי ב"גוגל טרנסלייט" או משהו כזה, בקושי ישתמשו, אולי בכלל לא ישתמשו במילים בצפתית, אולי אפילו לא שמעו את המושג הזה. ככל שעוברות השנים, פחות ופחות תלמידים, לפחות מאלה שמגיעים לקורס,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא מכירים את התחום כי פשוט הוא נמצא בכל מקום, נכון? מהווירטואל אסיסטנס הפופולריים, נגיד למשל כמו סירי ואחרים, כן? אלכסה של אמזון וכל מיני דברים כאלה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תרגום אוטומטי שהפך להיות משהו לגמרי סטנדרטי, עד כדי זה שיש, נכון, יש אתרים שבהם מראש כדיפולט הוא מתרגם לך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון, מתרגם את האינטראקציה, אני לא יודע אם יצא לכם נגיד באר בי אנד בי להשתמש בו לאחרונה, הוא פשוט כאילו כולם עונים לי בעברית, כן? כולם, לא משנה מאיזו מדינה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: קצת מוזר לטעמי, אבל כן, זה פשוט הפך להיות איזושהי שכבה בסיסית שכבר בחלק מהמקומות היא מוכנסת כברירת מחדל, כן? אז הרעיון הוא כמובן לקחת טקסט בשפה אחת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולתרגם אותו לשפה אחרת, כמו למשל כאן, את הערך ביוקיפדיה שעוסק בקיסריה רוהיטו. רייטינג אסיסטנס, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: דברים שמסייעים לכתיבה. אם פעם היה לנו רק ספל צ'קינג, נכון? ואחרי זה היה לנו מין קונטקסטואל ספל צ'קינג שיודע אם התכוונתם לאיטס עם גרש או איטס בלי גרש,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עכשיו כבר אנחנו מדברים על מנועים הרבה יותר מתוחכמים, נכון? שמצד אחד
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יכולים להציע לנו תיקונים לטעויות גרמר וטעויות ממש של אי תקינות של השפה, אבל במקרים אחרים ממש עוזרים לנו לנסח טקסטים מחדש, נכון? לבנות אותם אחרת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ברמה של משפטים ולעיתים אפילו ברמה של פסקאות או של טקסטים יותר ארוכים. כמה מכם, אגב, סתם מתוך עניין, כמה מכם משתמשים ב כעניין שבשגרה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מישהו כאן? אברהם, טל, אוקיי. אחלה, אז יש נציגות. מה אתה רואה? כתיבת מיילים, אני כבר לא כותב.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אה, אתה כבר לא כותב, אתה כותב, מישהו כזה תענה בנימוס, עושה פרפרייס ו... בדיוק. רושם לו בסיכום מה אני רוצה שהוא יכתוב, ואז הוא כבר כותב את זה יפה יפה. אה, אוקיי, מעולה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אז יש את הדברים האלה. אינפורמיישן אקסטרקשן, זה דווקא תחום שהוא קיים בתעשייה כבר לא מעט זמן, הוא כמובן עבר בוסט מאוד רציני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל הוא בעצם תחום שכבר היו חברות מצליחות שעסקו בו גם בשנות ה90 אפילו, בוודאי בשנות ה2000. אז בעצם אינפורמיישן אקסטרקשן, כן,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הכוונה פה לקחת איזשהו טקסט שכתוב בשפה טבעית, כלומר הוא אנסטרוקצ'רד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שנקרא, הוא פשוט מחרוזת של תווים ולהפוך את זה למשהו סטרקצ'ר, כן? למשל כמו טבלה או דאטה בייס או משהו כזה, כן? אז הנה דוגמה, לקחת את הטקסט הזה, ניו יורק טיימס קו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כפי שאתם רואים, הוא זיהה פה את האישויות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? כמו ניו יורק טיינס קואופריישן, כמו ראסל טי לואיס, כמו לנס אר פרימיס, כמו פרזידנט אנד צ'יף אופרייטינג אופיסר של משהו וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז הוא זיהה אותם, הוא נתן להם צבעים, ספציפית הצבעים כאן מציינים, מישהו אולי יכול לנחש מה הם מציינים? למה יש פה כחול, אדום וירוק?
Amit Levonai: אין רעיון? יש כאן חברה, שם ותפקיד, זה ממש מחלק אותם לפי זה. כן, בדיוק. אז הוא מחלק אותם לפי בן אדם, חברה ותפקיד. אוקיי? אתם רואים אחרי זה שבעצם הוא יוצר את העמודות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, הוא יוצר את העמודות של הטבלה הזאת. אז כן, אז הוא מוצא אותם ואז הוא מוצא יחסים ביניהם, כן? לא רק את האישיות אלא גם את היחסים, ראסל טי לואיס, את חיל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תפקיד בניו יורק טיימס יוז פייפר כפרזידנט וג'נרל מנג'ר וכן הלאה. כן, הדברים האלה, כפי שאתם יכולים לדמיין, יש להם הרבה מאוד ערך. למשל, נגיד שאתם עוסקים ב... נגיד שאתם איזושהי חברה מסחרית ורוצים לדעת מה הולך בשוק,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: המון מהמידע כיום מתפרסם בסושיאל מדיה, נכון? בבלוג פוסטס, בכל מיני מקומות שונים ושונים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כל מיני אימיילים שאולי יש לי סתם זרוקים בחברה שלי בכל מיני מקומות, אני רוצה להפוך את כל זה למשהו שיהיה לי קל אחרי זה לעשות עליו שאילתות, למיין,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, משהו סטאצ'ר. בקיצור, ברור שהרבה יותר קל לעשות את זה ברגע שזה מובנה וזה הערך, אז כמובן תחומים כמו ביזנס אינטליג'נס,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או להבנתי גם מיליטרי אינטליג'נס, למרות שאני מניח שעל חלקכם יש ניסיון בזה, לי ספציפית לא, עוסקים בדברים האלה הרבה. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לגבי דיוק, הדיוק כאן הוא מאוד משתנה לפי כמה זה מסובך, כמה היחסים המורכבים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמה המידע הזה כתוב ממש בצורה מפורשת או שצריך להעסיק אותו, אנחנו נדון בדברים האלה. מסתבר שזאת בעיה, במקרה הכללי שלה, בעיה מאוד מורכבת. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תחום שנהיה ככה פרץ בשנים האחרונות יותר, כן? פחות קלאסי, אבל גם שמעורר המון עניין היום, זה הנושא של אדיוטק בשילוב אייאיי, כן? אז...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: היום משתמשים בהרבה תחומים בחינוך, יש הטמעה מהירה של טכנולוגיות אייאיי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בין היתר כדי לייצר תכנים עבור קורסים, נגיד לייצר מצגות, לייצר סיכומים של שיעורים בצורה אוטומטית. זה דברים, כן, זה סוג אחד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני לא יודע אם מישהו מכם יצא לו להשתמש בתוכנה שבעצם בונה לו את תוכנית הלימודים באופן מותאם ביחס לטעויות. כן, למשל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חברה ידועה שעושה את זה בתחום לימוד שפה זרה זה דואלינגווה, כן? לא יודע אם כן יצא לכם. נכון, אז שם בעצם הדוגמאות שהוא נותן מונחות על בסיס ההישגים עד כה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכמובן אפשר להכליל את זה עוד הרבה יותר. וגם בתחום הזה יש מאמצים, לרנינג אסיסטנס, עם בוטים כדי לקבל משוב על תרגילים, כדי לשאול שאלות וכולי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן. תחום שהוא הייתי אומר התחיל מתוך עיבוד שפה טבעית או התחיל מתוך הטכנולוגיות שאנחנו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נלמד בקורס הזה, אבל מאז כבר פרש כנפיים ונהיה מפלצת בזכות עצמו, זה כמובן התחום של קוד ג'נריישן,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אגב, כמה מכם משתמשים, שוב, כעניין שגרתי, בכלים לכתיבת קוד?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אז כאן יש אפילו היענות יותר גדולה מאשר בתחום הכתיבה, אני רואה. אחלה. אז כן, מאוד נפוץ, בטח למי שנמצא בתעשייה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל גם בתחומים אחרים, נכון? פה ושם רואים כל מיני אנשים בטוויטר שגילו את קלוד קורד ולא מפסיקים לדבר על כמה הם עכשיו יכולים לבנות אפליקציות ולשרטט גרפים ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא יודע מה, למרות שאין להם שום עוסק בתכנון. בקיצור, יש כאן כל מיני רמות. אז הטכנולוגיה שאנחנו נדבר עליה בקורס הזה, של הטרנספורמרס ושל טקסט ג'נריישן,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ממנה זה התחיל, כל הסיפור הזה. כמובן שיש לו גם אספקטים מיוחדים לקוד, אבל הארכיטקטורה הבסיסית היא אותה ארכיטקטורה ואנחנו ניגע גם בזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמובן שלא כל השאלות נפתרו, כן? הרבה שאלות נותרו פתוחות. למשל, אם אנחנו מדברים על טקסט ג'נריישן, נגיד מה שנקרא לונג פורם, כלומר טקסטים ארוכים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא יודע כמה מכם ניסה, אבל חלקם לא באיכות מדהימה. נגיד למשל, אם ניסיתם לייצר סיפורים, סיפורים קצרים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בדרך כלל, אגב, מישהו מכם מנסה לייצר כאילו חומר קריאה או אתם יודעים, דברים כאלה מ... לא, מצ'אטבוטים או מ... כן, אז אנחנו קצת עובדים על זה עכשיו, על סיפורי בלשים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: במעבדה, הם איכשהו סיפורים קצרים, סיפורי בלשים. אני יכול להגיד שא', גם הסיפורים הקצרים של המודלים המתקדמים הם לא מי יודע מה, אנחנו מנסים קצת להגיד משהו יותר ספציפי, לא מי יודע מה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, בגדול, אבל בוודאי אם אתם מנסים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לבקש מהם לכתוב טקסט ארוך, הם לגמרי... פתאום מופיעות דמויות שלא קשורות לשום דבר שקרה קודם, נעלמות דמויות שהייתה איזושהי דמות מרכזית, פתאום לא שמעתם ממנה יותר, כל מיני דברים שונים ומשונים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בהחלט יש מה לעשות בתחום הזה, אבל זה בלי להוריד ולו פעימה מההתפתחות האדירה בתחום.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, מדהים, אולי אני אוריד את האוזניות. עדיין שומעים אותי בסדר?
Amit Levonai: כן, שומעים אותך? שומע אותך עדיין בסדר, כן. אוקיי. בסדר. עכשיו, צריך לומר שבעוד שעיבוד שפה טבעית התחיל מעיסוק בשפה פרופר, כלומר ביכולות שפתיות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כפי שהזכרתי קודם, שפה זה, יש הרבה שרואים אותה כמין ראי לאינטליגנציה באופן יותר רחב. ולמעשה יש, הכניסו לתוך המטרייה הזאת, לתוך האמברלה טרם הזה של אנלפי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם הרבה מאוד יכולות אחרות שהן לא אולי שפתיות בלבד, אבל ניתן לבטא אותן כטקסט. הרבה פעמים הן מבוטאות דרך שפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למשל יכולות לוגיות, יכולת להקיש הקשים, להסיק מסקנות, גם מסקנות לוגיות אבל גם מסקנות יותר קומון סנסיות, קומון סנסיות הם יודעים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מתי מישהו... כאילו, קומנדסנס יכול להיות למשל דברים סוציאליים, כן? מתי מישהו רומז לי ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כדי להמשיך לנושא הבא ומתי דווקא אולי מביע התעניינות ורצון
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאני אמשיך, כן? האם סביר שאם אני מציב, לא יודע, שאם אני רוצה לפתוח את הארון אז הידית שלה תהיה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם זה ארון נמוך, הידית שלה תהיה למעלה, ואם זה ארון גבוה, הידית שלה תהיה למטה. כן, לא בטוח, נכון? יש אולי ארונות נמוכים עם ידיות למטה, אבל...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יותר נדירים, אז כאילו זה מה שאני מתכוון בקומן סנס לדוגמה. דברים שהם לא הכרח לוגי, אבל הם איזשהו ידע שיש לנו על העולם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לנהל שיחה זה לא רק יכולת שפתית, נכון? זה העניין של... יש את העניין של אינטראקציה ו... מה שנקרא, נכון? שאני מעריך מה אתם חושבים ומה אתם חושבים שאני חושב.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. הדברים האלה הם לא שפה, לפחות לא יכולת שהיא רק שפתית, אבל הרבה פעמים גם היא נכללת בתוך המטרייה הזאת של איבוד שפה טבעית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכמובן כל ניסיון בעצם לתת איזושהי סקירה של התחום מחייבת להזכיר איזשהן מילות אזהרה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שבעצם התחום נע מאוד מהר, אפליקציות מסוימות נהיות פתאום טרנדיות, אחרות נזנחות, חלק באיזשהו מובן נפתרות או לפחות אינסטנסים מסוימים שלהם נפתרים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז ככה התחום נמצא בשינויים מאוד מהירים וזה כמובן גם משפיע על האופי של הקורס ובטח הניסיון לתת סקירה שלו. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וזה איזשהו מאמר שיצא, כן, שוב בהקשר הזה של מה שנקרא, מה שנקרא אייג'יאיי, כן? אולי מישהו שמע את המושג הזה? מישהו מכם?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רוצה לשמוע? כן? אז אולי מישהו יכול להסביר למה הכוונה? מישהי?
Nathan: לא. אוקיי. בגדול, בינה מלאכותית כללית שיודעת ללמוד דפוסים ממש כמו בן אדם ולעשות בעצם כמעט כל פעולה כמו בן אדם.
Nathan: לעשות מה, סליחה? כל פעולה, אבל גם ללמוד בעצם כל דבר, ממש כמו בן אדם, שלא כמו היום שצריך להביא
Nathan: דאטה ספציפי כדי להשיג למידה ספציפית, ואז משהו מאוד ספציפי שהכלי עושה, כמו טקסט או תמונה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אוקיי, תודה, בדיוק. אז כאילו זה בעצם מושג, צריך לומר זה מושג מסחרי, אני לא יודע איך לקרוא לו, זה מושג שיווקי, הוא לא בדיוק מושג מדעי, זאת אומרת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אין לו הגדרה באמת ברורה, אבל זה בדיוק, אני חושב שנתן או נתן הסביר את זה בצורה טובה, שבעצם אמר זה איזושהי יכולת שהיא גם יכולת כזאת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: פעולה כללית בשפה ויכולת למידה כללית, וזה משהו שכן, שהרבה פעמים מוצג בתור הגביע הקדוש של
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כל החקירה באייאיי, מערכת שהיא כללית לחלוטין. ובהקשר הזה באמת, שוב, הקשר בין מודל שפה לבין אינטליגנציה, אז יצא מאמר שזכה לדי הרבה הדים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ספארקס אוף ארטיפישל ג'נרל אינטליג'נס, ארלי אקספרימנטס ווג'י פי טי פור. כן, מאמר של מייקרוסופט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שכמובן היא משקיעה מאוד רצינית באופן אייאיי המפתחת של ג'י פי טי 4, אז גם את זה צריך לקחת בחשבון, אז אל תקנו את הכותרת כפשוטה, אבל כאילו רק כדי, כן, רק כדי לתת דוגמה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לכך שבעצם מודלי השפה נתפסים היום כאיזשהו פרונטיר בכלל לפיתוח יכולות אייאיי כלליות. נגיד למשל, כן פתרון של בעיות במתמטיקה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או לפעמים גם נכון כל מיני, הרבה פעמים מכניסים כל מיני שילובים ביזאריים כאלה כמו תכתוב הוכחה למשהו אבל זה גם תתחרז, תכתוב הוראות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לאיך לתקן מכשיר וידאו ישן בסגנון תנך המלך ג'יימס וכל מיני דברים כאלה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אגב, אתם יודעים למה, מאיפה, כאילו מה המוטיבציה לדוגמאות הביזאריות האלה, חוץ מאולי ניסיון לשעשע? למה הם לא סתם בחרו משהו קצת יותר סביר?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שמישהו אולי אי פעם יכול לשאול.
Elad Elfasi: לא, אוקיי. בשביל לראות אולי אם הוא יכול להביא משהו חדש ולא רק להקריא משהו שכבר היה. כן, בדיוק. אז בעצם אחד מהקשיים הגדולים באבלואציה של מודלי שפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה שבעצם הם הפעילו להם כל פיסת מידע שכנראה מצאו, ומעבר לזה גם לא בדיוק אומרים לנו איך ימנו אותם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? לא אומרים לנו איך ימנו אותם, מה יכניס ומה לא יכניס. יכול להיות שימנו אותם ספציפית לייצר הוראות לתיקון מכשיר וידאו על פי סגנון תנך המלך ג'יימס, כן? מי יודע בכלל?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה הם עשו שם, אבל כאילו אומרים, אם ניתן להם דוגמאות מספיק מופרכות, אז כנראה שאתם יודעים, אם הם לא באמת היו יודעים להכליל למודלים האלה, אז זה לא, לא היו מצליחים. זה בערך הרציונל. וגם על אוולואציה אנחנו נדבר בהמשך.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז אוקיי, אז הנה האתגר שלנו בקורס הזה, או בכלל בתחום, אנחנו מנסים לגשר בין שני קטבים או שני טיפוסים של שפות שהם מאוד שונים אחד מהשני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שפה טבעית ושפת מחשב. אז שפה טבעית, הנה רק כמה מהמאפיינים שהם שונים. שפה טבעית היא אמביגיבס, היא רב משמעית, יש בה עמימות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו אף פעם לא יודעים באופן דפניטיבי מה בדיוק אמר, לא כל מילה, אבל הרבה מילים יכולות להתפרש בכמה דרכים, הרבה טקסטים יכולים להתפרש בכמה דרכים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. שפת מחשב,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ככלל שואפת להיות אנאמביגואס, כלומר בתחומים שבהם היא יודעת לבצע פעולות, בגדול שואפת לזה שהמשתמש
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יציין בצורה שאין בה ריבוי משמעות מה המערכת צריכה לעשות. שוב, הכול עם כוכביות וכולי, אבל רק כאיזושהי הצגה סכמטית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שפה טבעית היא הרבה פעמים אימפליציטית, כן? חלק מהדברים, כן? כמו מה שציינתי קודם, הסיטואציות החברתיות, נכון? האם אנשים פה לא מדליקים מצלמה בגלל שאני לא יודע מה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הם עכשיו נמצאים במקלט או שאולי הם, לא יודע, הלכו להכין לעצמם כוס קפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? אז דווקא עצם זה שהרבה פעמים תקשורת אנושית, יש בה איזשהו מרכיב שהוא אימפליציטי, נכון? ולפעמים זה בסדר שאני לא אדע, כי זה חלק מהאינטראקציה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולפעמים זה דווקא האימפליציטיות הזאת משדרת לי משהו שאני אמור להבין בעצמי, נכון? לא יודע.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם נגיד סימנתם איזו תנועה של אי נוחות, אז אולי זמן לעבור נושא או משהו כזה, כן? אולי כבר חפרתי מספיק.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר. לשפה טבעית יש הרבה פעמים קונוטציות תרבותיות עשירות, נכון? אנחנו מפנים, מתייחסים לאירועי עבר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ליצירות ספרותיות אולי קנוניות, לכל מיני טרנדים שקורים, לאירועי היומיום וכן הלאה. שפת מחשב בגדול.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תפעילו את אותו קוד על אותו קומפיילר, נכון? או משהו כזה, גם בעוד שנה, שנתיים, עשר, יצא אותו דבר. איך אנחנו מכניסים את העניין הזה? שפה טבעית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מניחה הרבה ידע עולם, כן? מניחה שיש לנו הרבה ידע עולם, הרבה מהדברים אני לא אטרח לציין, כן? נגיד למשל, אם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם אתם, אני לא יודע מה, אני מבקש מכם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מבקש מהבן שלי שיביא לי תפוח מהמטבח, אז יכול להיות שהוא יודע איפה התפוח הזה, וגם אם הוא לא יודע, אז יש מקומות שאני לא מצפה שהוא יביא לי אותם ממנו, נכון? נגיד למשל מפח האשפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למרות שאולי יש שם תפוח ופח האשפה נמצא במטבח, נכון? אבל פשוט איכשהו לא, זה לא, כנראה לא מה שרציתי ממנו, אם לא ציינתי את זה ממש מפורשות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז אתם מבינים, יש כאן פער די גדול. איך מתגברים על זה? אוקיי, זה לא קל. אוקיי. אז מה בכל זאת ניסו לעשות? תמיד טוב להתחיל מ...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמה דקות של היסטוריה, אני חושב. אז בגדול, התחום, אין על פי צריך לומר, הוא ימיו ארוכים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כימי המחשב הדיגיטלי באופן כללי. זאת אומרת, עבודה לתרגום אוטומטי התחילה ממש מיד אחרי מלחמת העולם השנייה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זאת אומרת, בדיוק בזמן שהתחילו לבנות מחשבים דיגיטליים שניתן לתכנת אותם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובעיקר העבודה בתחום בשנות ה50 וה60 עסקה ביותר בתוצאות תיאורטיות או בכל מיני פרופס אוף קונספט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, זאת אומרת, ככלל אני לא מכיר ממש עבודות שיצרו דברים יותר מדי שימושיים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל ניסו לראות איזה בעיות קשות, איזה בעיות קלות, ניסו להעלות רעיונות, ניסו לפתח תיאוריה של התחום.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: והאמת שחבר הסגל, זה שידוע לפחות בפולקלור כראשון בעולם שהיה לו משרה לעסוק באוניברסיטה, לעסוק ב...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תרגום אוטומטי היה יהושע בר הלל, שהיה גם חבר סגל באוניברסיטה העברית, אבל הוא ספציפית היה במינוי באותו זמן באםאייטי. אז כבוד, כן, כבוד מקומי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, בשנות ה70 וה80 אנחנו רואים שכבר שיטות השתכללו, אנחנו כבר רואים אפליקציות אמיתיות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל עדיין על דומיינים מאוד מצומצמים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נגיד למשל, אז משהו שעוסק בניתוח של דוחות מזג אוויר, אוקיי? שיש לו סך הכל שפה מאוד מצומצמת, אוצר מילים מצומצם, תחביר מצומצם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או מערכת אחרת שעשו, אחת המערכות, ככה מערכות החלוציות בתחום אינפורמיישן אקסטרה. כן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אינפורמיישן אקסטרקשן וסרץ' היה מה שנקרא ליונר פרוג'קט, שבגדול עסק
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: באחזור מידע קטלוגי על ממצאים שהחזירו משימות אפולו מהירח. מסתבר שהם הביאו המון המון אבנים, לך תחפש את מה שאתה צריך בתוך ערימה של אבנים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: והם יצרו איזושהי מערכת ממוחשבת שעוזרת לך להבין מה נמצא, איפה, וכן, זה נקרא מערכת לונה. ובגדול אנחנו רואים שם מערכות שהן מבוססות חוקים, כלומר אין שם סטטיסטיקה ככלל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יש שם הרבה מאוד מידול של התחביר והסמנטיקה של שפה, זאת אומרת זה אנשים שעסקו בתחום ובהחלט אנשים שהבינו והתעניינו בשפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל כאמור, הצלחות בתחומים מוגבלים. בשנות ה90 אנחנו רואים כניסה מאוד מסיבית של שיטות מבוססות קורפוס, קורפוס זה אומר בלטינית גוף,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: והכוונה בקורס הזה, קורפוס הכוונה לגוף טקסט, כלומר אסופה של טקסטים, לא משנה אם זה ספרים או דפי ווב או כל דבר אחר. אז בגדול שיטות סטטיסטיות מבוססות קורפוסים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואוולואציה אמפירית. וכאן אנחנו בגדול רואים מעבר משיטות שיש בהן הרבה מאוד הנחות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לשוניות שיש בהן הרבה מאוד מידול שפתי וקשר לבלשנות גם, מענפים מסוימים שלה, לשיטות יותר סטטיסטיות, יותר ברוט פורס,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שמצד אחד הרבה פעמים הולידו הרבה טעויות, אבל מצד שני אפשרו בפעם הראשונה איזושהי הפעלה, מה שנקרא,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אינקלוסיב דומיין, כן? לא באיזשהו דומיין ספציפי, אלא באמת מערכות יותר כלליות. לדוגמה לזה, אפשר לתת את מה שנקרא את האיי.בי.אם טרנסליישן מודלס, אז איי.בי.אם בתחילת שנות ה90, לדעתי 93, אם אני לא טועה, פרסמה סדרה של מודלי תרגום,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שהן לאותו זמן עם הצלחות מרשימות, בעיקר אנגלית צרפתית, ושהן היו מבוססות על מעט מאוד מידול של שפה והרבה מאוד סטטיסטיקה מבוססת קורפוסים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בשנות ה2000, שיטות של משין לרנינג יותר מתקדמות נכנסו.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו רואים שהשיטות האלה, אנלפי הפך להיות לא רק תחום שמשתמש בשיטות של לרנינג ובשיטות סטטיסטיות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אלא גם תחום שבעצם מייצר שיטות חדשות ומייצר בעיות חדשות במשין לרנינג ומזין את הקהילה הזאת בצורה יותר אינטנסיבית. וכמובן ההעמקה של...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: העמקה של ה... כן, נושא של ויל וורלד אפליקיישנס, ומאז בעשור האחרון וביתר שאת, מאז פרסום של ג'י פי טי 3 ואחרי זה של...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: צ'אד ג'י פי טי, אנחנו רואים שזה הצ'אד ג'י פי טי זה עכשיו בערך שלוש וחצי שנים, אנחנו רואים מה שנקרא את הלאג' לנגודג' מודלס מושלים בכיפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ויש המון עניין, כפי שאתם ודאי שמעתם וכפי שצוינו אחרונה, בתחומים שבעבר היו נחשבים כמעט מדע בדיוני,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמו אלה ממולטימודלים שיכולים לקבל גם דאטה טקסטואלי, גם דאטה אודיטורי, גם דאטה ויזואלי, גם כל מיני דברים. אנחנו רואים הרבה דגש על יעילות, בגלל שהמערכות האלה הן סופר בזבזניות ב...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנרגיה ובזמן ריצה ואיך אפשר לייעל דברים, ובאמת אנליזה סמנטית מתוחכמת הרבה יותר משהכרנו.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אז זה ככה הייתה סקירה על קצה המזלג, אני רואה שהגיע הזמן להפסקה. אז בואו נצא לרבע שעה הפסקה, נחזור דקה או שתיים אחרי אחת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אז ממשיכים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טוב, אז נמשיך. בסדר. אז
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם עברנו כמה דקות על ההיסטוריה של התחום, לגבי המצב היום. חשוב לי להדגיש שהטכנולוגיה החדשה שהתפתחה בשנים האחרונות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: היא נתנה מענה לבעיות שהרבה מאוד זמן היו פתוחות בעיבוד שפה טבעית, כמו למשל נושא התרגום האוטומטי עבר קפיצה דרמטית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, תודות לטכנולוגיה החדשה, לטרנספורמרים שנדבר עליהם בהמשך. כל הנושא של דיסאמביגואציה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, הפגת עמימות. לא הייתי אומר שזו בעיה פתורה לחלוטין, אבל כבר המודלים הרבה פחות נופלים בכל מיני מקרים שבעבר היו נפוצים, שבו לבני אדם היה ברור
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מהו המובן שבו השתמשו במילה או במבנה התחבירי או במשפט הזה, והמכונה הייתה נכשלת בה. יחד עם זאת, יש שאלות חשובות שנשארו פתוחות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לדוגמה, שילוב של מה שנקרא דיסקריט ריזונינג, כלומר של שימוש ב... כן, איזשהו היגיון דיסקרטי כמו מתמטיקה, כן, אריתמטיקה נגיד, לוגיקה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יחד עם הבנת שפה, זה נושא שעדיין רחוק מפתרון, למרות שגם שם רואים התקדמות משמעותית, אבל זה קצת מטעה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם כי הרבה פעמים נותנים למודלים האלה לפתור תרגילים במתמטיקה, אבל בסופו של דבר אנחנו לא כל כך יודעים על מה הם התאמנו, ובגלל זה זה גם קצת קשה להעריך את היכולות שלהם, ויש כאלה שטוענים, שוב, אני לא...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאלת האבליות היא מורכבת כאן, אבל יש כאלה שטוענים שבעצם יכולת ההכללה האמיתית שלהם היא יחסית מוגבלת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, למרות כל ההתפתחויות האדירות, עדיין בסופו של דבר אם אנחנו רוצים להרים דאטה בייס לשימוש, אני לא יודע מה, דאטה בייס לצורכי שכר לחברה שלנו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ככל הנראה נעשה את זה עם דאטה בייס סימבולי, לא נשתמש לזה ב...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מערכת של... במערכת נוירונלית, כן? במערכת של דיפלרנינג, אפילו אם נשתמש בה כדי בסופו של דבר לבנות ממשק לדאטה בייס הזה, כן? והסיבה שזה עדיין לא מספיק אמין, זה עושה טעויות, לעיתים טעויות מביכות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: באופן כללי אפשר לומר, היינו שמחים, זה שהמודלים האלה לא מצליחים לפתור את כל בעיות העולם ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אתם יודעים, לעשות איזשהם היקשים סופר מורכבים שגם רוב בני אדם מתקשים איתם, אנחנו אומרים דיינו, אבל יש מקרים שבהם גם אם אתה לא יודע את התשובה הנכונה לפחות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו מצפים שפשוט תגיד אני לא יודע, נכון? ולא לפלוט משהו שהוא בבירור לא נכון. אנחנו עדיין לא נמצאים ברמה הזאת ואני גם יכול לתת דוגמאות אחר כך.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנלפי שיכול להכליל לכל שפה, אז אנחנו רואים שיפור בהחלט ב... כן, ב... עיסוי של שפות שונות ומגוונות, אבל עדיין...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: השפות הגדולות ובראשן אנגלית, אנחנו רואים בהם ביצועים הרבה יותר טובים בשפות האחרות, בוודאי אם אנחנו מדברים על שפות שיש להן סקריפט שהוא לא לטיני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, מה שגורם לדגרדציה בביצועים כמו למשל עברית, ערבית, סינית, יפנית וכולי. בקורס הזה אנחנו נתחיל מדברים מאוד קלאסיים, כן? מ...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: דברים שבעצם רעיונות ומודלים שקיימים כבר הרבה שנים, שהם, מתוכם כמובן לא בחרתי את הנושאים שלדעתי
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הם הכי רלוונטיים גם היום, אבל אני בכוונה לא קופץ ישר למודלים החדשים ביותר ושימוש בדיפ לרנינג, כי אני חושב שהרבה פעמים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: המודלים האלה קצת מטשטשים את הבעיות האמיתיות שבעצם אנחנו צריכים להתמודד איתן. אם איכשהו פותרים אולי אותן או מפגינים ביצועים מרשימים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מספקים לנו מעט מאוד תובנה לגבי האופן שבו הם עשו את זה, ולכן גם מספקים תובנה די מוגבלת על בעצם אופי הבעיה שאנחנו מתמודדים איתה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בשלב המאוחר יותר של הקורס כמובן גם נגיע לטכניקות יותר מתקדמות וגם יש קורסים מתקדמים שניתנים בבית הספר בעיבוד שפה טבעית, למי מכם ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יהיה פה שנה הבאה גם, בהחלט אפשרי ומומלץ לקחת, נדבר על זה בסוף הקורס. אוקיי. עוד ככה כמה סוגי בעיות ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מאוד, בוא נגיד, הניעו הרבה מהמחקר בשנים האחרונות. נושא של סמריזיישן, תקצור, אנחנו מקבלים טקסט ואנחנו רוצים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לתקצר אותו, אולי זה בצורה מה שנקרא אקסטרקטיב, כלומר להוציא ממנו, למרקר, זה כמו למרקר משפטים חשובים או מושגים חשובים, כן? טו אקסטרקט פרום דה טקסט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או אבסטרקטיב, שזה אומר בעצם לכתוב טקסט חדש שמתקצר את זה. משימה שהיא כמו הרבה מהבעיות ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הכי מעניינות באלפי, בעיה שהיא לא לגמרי מוגדרת, אם תחשבו על זה. מה זה אומר סיכום טוב?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מאוד שאלה מה אתם רוצים, נכון? האם זה סיכום לבית הספר שהמטרה שלו היא לבדוק אם יש לי יכולות טובות להטמיע חומר, לקרוא ולהטמיע חומר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אולי זה סיכום שאני משתמש בו לצורך מסוים ואז כדאי שאני אדע מה הצורך הזה, כי זה מה שהולך להנחות אותי במה יכנס ומה לא יכנס לסיפור. אולי זה כדי לכתוב ערך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: איציק לופדי ואז משהו אחר וכן הלאה. והבעיה הזאת היא בעיה שבעצם לאורך השנים התעסקו בה המון,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואנחנו רואים יכולות הולכות ומשתפרות, אבל גם כאן עדיין אנחנו רואים מה שנקרא אלוסימטד, אנטיטיז, כן? או הזיות. מישהו מכם יצא לשמוע את המושג הזה, הזיה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של מודלי שפה, כן? זהו, אז זה היה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם לזה אין בדיוק הגדרה לגמרי פורמלית והשאלה איפה בדיוק עובר הגבול בין הזיה לסתם טעות זה נושא לוויכוח, אבל בגדול הרעיון הוא בערך משהו כזה, זה דוגמה פשוט ממאמר ב2020,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אז בעצם אתם נותנים למערכת איזשהו מסמך, נגיד כאן זה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, כאן זה איזשהו מסמך שעוסק בבחירות, כן, באיזשהו מחוז בחירה בבריטניה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ריצ'מנט פארק ונורת' קינגסטון, ככה זה נקרא המחוז הזה, לא נורא משנה, מדברים פה על מישהו שהתמודד, הוא ממלכת הפרלמנט, הוא זכה ב70 מהקולות, הוא התמודד מול מישהו
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אחר, אנדרו בוף, שהוא הלונדון אסמבלי, שהוא לונדון אסמבלי ממבר, כן, ועוד אחד שהוא, כן, לונדון דפיוטי מאייר פור קריים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סטפן, פור קריים אנד פוליסינג וכן הלאה וכן הלאה, בסדר? אז זה מספר איזשהו סיפור חדשותי די סטנדרטי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואז, הנה תראו סיכום של איזושהי מערכת, והוא אומר, יוקיפ לידר, נייג'ל גולדסמית', הס בין אלקטד איז דה ניו מייר אוף לונדון טו אלקט אה אה ניו קונסרבטיב אם פי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי? אז זה כאן... עכשיו, אם תשימו לב למשפט הזה, פשוט משהו קצת לא ברור, הוא מדבר על מישהו שנקרא נייג'ל גולדסמית', כן? שהוא סך הכול לא נראה מופרך בהתחנכון, הוא לא... זה לא איזה מישהו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, עם שם ישראלי או לא יודע, משהו לא קשור, כן? זה מישהו שלמעשה מורכב ככל הנראה משתי שמות שמופיעים במאמר. נכון, אחד זה גולדסמיט, רק שכאן זה זאק גולדסמיט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וניג'ל, שגם הוא מופיע פה איפשהו, אבל לא ניג'ל קונס. ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואז הוא אומר שזה אלקטד איז דה ניו מייר אוף לונדון, וזה גם בכלל לא זה, אבל כן נזכר שם, הדפיוטי מייר אוף לונדון. בקיצור, כפי שאתם רואים, הקטע עם ההזיות האלה הרבה פעמים זה שקשה לתפוס אותם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כי א', הם קונטקסטואלי פלוזיבל, נכון? איכשהו בהקשר זה נשמע כמו משהו שאולי יכול להיות נכון. אפילו השמות הם הרבה פעמים אולי שמות ממש מהטקסט או אישויות מהטקסט,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: והוא אומר דברים שהם איכשהו קשורים אבל הוא עושה מהם סלט, בקיצור. וזה בדיוק הדבר שמאוד מקשה על הסיפור, נכון? אם זה מאוד מקשה על הסיפור שלנו כמשתמשים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הרבה פעמים קשה לנו להבין מה הזיה ומה לא הזיה בלי ממש לקרוא את הטקסט בצורה מעמיקה, אבל אז אנחנו אומרים, טוב, זה די פספס את הפואנטה אם ככה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז זה בהחלט בעיה רצינית. אוקיי. וצ'אטבוטים, אי אפשר לסיים את ההקדמה בלי להזכיר צ'אטבוטים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שהיום משתמשים בהם לכל מיני סטינגס, כן? צ'יט צ'אט, סתם אנשים ששופכים את ליבם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או סתם מפטפטים איתם על הא ודא, שיווק, שירות לקוחות וכל מיני דברים, זה נכנס בצורה יותר ויותר מקיפה בייחוד אם זה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שנקרא, רלטיבלי לואו סטייק אפליקיישנס, נכון? זאת אומרת, אולי זה בסדר שהוא ייקח ממני הזמנה ב... לא יודע, מזון מהיר, כן? במסעדת מזון מהיר, אבל לא יודע אם אני אתן לו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא יודע מה, לאשר את התוכניות של המעבורת חלל הבאה שאני בונה, ובהחלט אנחנו רואים הטמעה של זה. אוקיי, אז זה לגבי אפליקציות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עכשיו פרספקטיבה אחרת על התחום, היא בעצם דרך הפרספקטיבה של הקשיים. מה בעצם קשה בלנתח שפה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז כל מיני דברים, כן? כפי שגם ראינו קודם, בואו קצת נתעמק בכמה מהם. אחד זה המקיויטי שהזכרנו, נכון? שפה טבעית היא ככלל עמומה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יש לה הרבה פעמים, הדרך שמבטאים את זה בחקר השפה זה לומר שיש לה הרבה אנדרליין סטרוקצ'ר או הרבה לייטנס סטרוקצ'ר, זאת אומרת, יש הרבה דברים שהם בעצם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חלק מהמבנה או חלק מהמובן של הטקסט, שהם לא כתובים ממש שחור על גבי לבן במפורש כחלק מהסטרינג, כן? וזה יכול להיות משמעות של מילים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון, יש הרבה מאוד מילים עמומות בכל שפה, כן? עכבר יכול להיות גם עכבר של מחשב וגם עכבר
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: החיה וג'נריישן יכול להיות גם כאילו חילול, כן? יצירה, כמו טקסט ג'נריישן, אבל גם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: דור, למשל, וכן הלאה וכן הלאה, אבל לא רק מילים הן המומות. מורפמות יכולות להביע, כן, מה שנקרא חלקים ממילים, כמו הטיות או סיומות, גם הם יכולים להיות המומים, נכון?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תשמח, זה יכול להיות בעברית, גם היא תשמח וגם אתה תשמח. נכון? הרבה מילים ממוטות באותה צורה, למרות שאחד זה גוף שני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, זה גוף שני זכר, והשני זה גוף שלישי נקבה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אס באנגלית יכול לשמש גם כהטיה של פועל, נכון? כמו ווקס, וגם כהטיה של שמצם, של רבים, כן? כמו דוגס.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למשפטים הרבה פעמים יכולים להיראות אותו דבר, אבל שיהיה להם כמה משמעויות, כמו... דו טקסטבוק אקזמפל דה ריסרצ'ר ווטשטט קרוקודיל ודה טלסקופ.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון שהשאלה פה היא אם הקרוקודיל הוא עם הטלסקופ או שהוא צפה בו עם הטלסקופ, החוקר. והדבר המעניין הוא שיחד עם זה שהשפה היא עמומה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כלומר, היא עושה אנדרספסיפיקציה, כן? הדברים הם לא לגמרי מוגדרים במלואם ככלל. יש בה גם הרבה רידנדנסי, כן? יתירות, זאת אומרת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יש הרבה דרכים להגיד את אותו הדבר ככלל, ובעצם אנחנו רואים את שני הכיוונים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז למשל, אקסמפלס של כותרות בקשר לאמביגרטי, כותרות בגלל שהן כל כך מצומצמות, הרבה פעמים הן יוצרות כל מיני דו משמעויות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: משעשעות כמו שזה נגיד יכול לומר מורה שחובט בילדים עצלים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון, אבל לא בהכרח. זה גם יכול להיות שהשביתות של המורים גורמות לילדים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, לא להיות מועסקים וכן הלאה. בתי חולים נתבעים על ידי רופאים בגובה שבעה רגל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או שזה שבע רופאים של קופות הרגליים וכן הלאה. אז בקיצור, אתם מבינים את הפואנט. מאוד נפוץ. ולמעשה, אם אתם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וזו סיבה שבעצם העמימות הייתה בעיה כל כך רצינית ובמידה רבה עדיין עבור מודלי שפה לאורך השנים, זה שבעצם יש הרבה עמימות בשפה שאנחנו בכלל לא שמים לב אליה כבני אדם, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז נגיד למשל, הנה סתם דוגמה קלה, כן? רוקנרול קונצרטס. אני חושב שלכולכם, אף אחד כאן לא חשב לקרוא את זה כמו כאן. כלומר, שמדובר באבן וקונצרטים של רוק, נכון?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למרות שזה יכול להיות נכון, יש רוק קונצרטס, יש אבן, אולי זה מי שרוצה לדבר על אבן ועל קונצרטים של רוק, אבל כנראה שהוא רוצה לדבר על קונצרטים של רוקנרול.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון? כאילו אפילו זה נראה מתחכם, נכון? לחשוב, אפילו להעלות את הדוגמה השנייה, ותזכרו שלמחשבים, בהיעדר הנחיה, אין סיבה להטיף אפשרות אחת על האחרת, אוקיי?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובעצם ברגע שאתם לוקחים את המכפלות הקומבינטוריות של כל האפשרויות השונות לנתח משפטים, זה מתפוצץ לרמות שקשה להאמין, זה מתפוצץ תוך כלום למיליונים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של קומבינציות שונות לפענח את המשפטים בצורות שרוב רובן בלתי מתקבלות על הדעת ובכלל אנחנו לא חושבים עליהן, אבל על פניו הן אפשריות. ועל זה לפעמים קוראים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? והשאלה היא מה אפשר לעשות עם זה? אולי לא הפתיע אתכם לגנות שהדרך העיקרית להתמודד עם זה היא באמצעות סטטיסטיקה. כן? אז בוא ניקח אפילו את הדוגמה הפשוטה הזאת. נכון, אתם אומרים טוב,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: איך אני כל כך בטוח שרוקנרול קונצרטס זה באמת רוקנרול קונצרטס ולא רוק אנד רול קונצרטס? למשל, אולי כי רוקנרול זה מין ביטוי כבול, כן? כלומר, הוא מופיע ביחד
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רוק ורול מופיע ביחד הרבה יותר פעמים משהייתי מצפה שהם יופיעו ביחד
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סתם על בסיס השכיחויות האינדיבידואליות שלהם. יש שם איזשהו קשר סטטיסטי, אולי אפשר למנף אותו כדי להבין שרוקנרול הוא בעצם ביטוי, ואם הוא ביטוי אז כנראה מדובר ב...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רוקנבול קונצרטס ולא ברוקנבול קונצרטס. אז סוג כזה של לוגיקה בעצם מופעלת, בין אם בצורה מפורשת או...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מובלעת בהרבה מקרים. אוקיי, ועכשיו לגבי רידנדנסי, הצד השני, כן, אז יש כמובן הרבה דרכים גם להביע את אותו רעיון, נגיד, מה האקס עושה לעבודה שלו? מהי העבודה של האקס? מהי העבודה של האקס?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיופיישן, וואט דאז אקס דו, וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. אבל, ולפעמים גם יש מערכונים משעשעים שמנצלים את הצורות השונות האלה להגיד את אותו דבר למטרות בידור, מישהו מכם, סלולה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רוצה לא לצפות במערכון שמוצג כאן בתמונה מימין.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא, אוקיי. בעבר היו יותר, כנראה שזה הופך להיות פחות. זה מערכון משנות ה70, אם אני לא טועה, אז זה בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בקיצור, מדובר כאן על סיפור כזה, זה מערכון של חבורת מונטי פייטון, אם שמעתם עליה, כן, בעצם להקה, כאילו חבורה של קומיקאים בריטים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכאן ג'ון קליז מחזיק תוכי, שהוא תוכי נורבגי, והוא קנה אותו מהבחור הזה לפני כמה דקות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל התברר לו בעצם אחרי שהוא קנה אותו שהתוכי הזה שהוא מכר לו הוא בעצם מת, אוקיי? ולמעשה ככל הנראה הוא היה מת כבר בזמן שהוא מכר לו אותו והוא פשוט מסמר אותו ל...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, איכשהו ל... איך נקרא ל... כן, לפרץ', כאילו למקום שעליו הוא עומד כדי שהתוכי לא ייפול. אבל אחרי שהוא עזב תחנות הוא מיד גילה שהתוכי הזה מת ועכשיו הוא...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חוזר לחנות ותובע ממנו את הכסף חזרה. אבל כמובן שהמוכר מסרב להקשיב ומסרב כאילו לקלוט את המסר, מנסה לשכנע אותו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שבעצם בכלל לא מדובר בתוכי מת, אלא שהתוכי הוא חי. ואז הוא אומר לו את הדבר הבא, את המונולוג הבא, כן? הקונה:"הספסט און, דיספריט איז נו מור".
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי? אז כפי שאתם רואים, המסר היה כנראה, הובהר כנראה על ידי כל אחד מהביטויים האלה בנפרד, וכן, על אחת כמה וכמה, יש הרבה מאוד ערכים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מסתבר לפחות באנגלית, לבטא את הרעיון הזה. אוקיי. שאלות לגבי אמביגיוטי סלאש רדנדנסי?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גלילות. אוקיי. אז בעצם עכשיו אנחנו עוברים למחוזות הניתוח הסטטיסטי ואנחנו אומרים בסדר, אז יש הרבה דברים בשפה, אנחנו כבר מבינים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאנחנו כנראה נרצה לייצג אותם על ידי סטטיסטיקות, או נרצה ללמוד אותם באופן סטטיסטי. איך נעשה את זה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אז אנחנו פשוט נתקל במספיק דוגמאות מכל דבר שאותו אנחנו רוצים לנתח, מילים נגיד, צירופי מילים, ביטויים, מבנים תחביריים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה, ואנחנו לאט לאט נקלוט את אופני השימוש.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הקושי שיש בגישה הזאת זה מה שנקרא דלילות הנתונים. ומה הכוונה? הכוונה היא שאפילו אם יש לכם דאטה סטים עצומים, קורפוסים עצומים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ההתפלגות, מסתבר, של תופעות לשוניות היא מאוד לא אחידה. אז נגיד למשל נסתכל על... אפילו על מילים, כן? אנחנו רוצים לראות איך מתפלגת השכיחות של מילים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כפונקציה של הרנק שלהם, כן? כלומר, כפונקציה, קודם אני שם מה השכיחות של המילה הכי נפוצה, אחרי זה השנייה, אחרי זה השלישית וכן הלאה. ואז כמובן שמה שאני אקבל זה גרף יורד, נכון? או לפחות מונוטוני לא עולה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל השאלה באיזה קצב הוא יורד. ומסתבר שהוא יורד מאוד מאוד מהר. אז אם אני מסתכל פה על איזשהו קורפוס, לא בדיוק זוכר איזה, ומסתכל על 100 אלף המילים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הנפוצות ביותר. אז מה שאני רואה זה שיש לי פה איזה מילה אחת בהתחלה או שתיים, לא יודע, מספר זעום של מילים שהם מאוד מאוד גבוה, אולי זה אחת אפילו. יש לי פה עוד טיפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל פחות או יותר מאפס פלוס אפסילון, זה כבר מאוד קרוב לאפס. אם אני עושה זום אין על ה... כן, מהמילים הנפוצות ביותר, אני רואה שאפילו שם,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יש לי ירידה יחסית דרמטית, גם אם פה אני מצליח להבחין שזה לא ממש יורד לאפס.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ומה זה אומר מבחינתנו? למה זה חדשות רעות מבחינתנו? שבעצם ההתפלגות היא כזאת סקיוט, כן? כל כך לא אחידה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, תכף נחזור לזה. אז תכף אולי אני אסביר עוד טיפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז בוא נגיד שנסתכל על הלוג לוג פלוט, כן? אני מסתכל על הלוג בציר האיקס ועל הלוג בציר הווי, סולם לוגוריתמי, ואני מסתכל שוב על אותו גרף כמו מקודם. אז אני רואה קשר שהוא קשר די ליניארי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או במילים אחרות, אנחנו רואים שדי ליניארי וגם יש שטוענים שהוא בערך בשיפוע אחד. מינוס אחד, כלומר, אולי זה לא בדיוק נכון, אבל הוא לא מאוד רחוק מזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובעצם מה שאנחנו אם ככה רואים, זה שפחות או יותר נכון שסכום הלוגים של התדירות ושל הרנק הוא קבוע.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שזה נקרא גם חוק זיפ, שזה בעצם אומר שהתדירות היא איזשהו חוק חזקה, היא איזושהי חזקה מסוימת של הרנק.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: התפלגויות כאלה, מה שנקרא פאוור לורד דיסטריביושן, הן מתאפיינות בזה שבעצם עיקר המסה נמצא במילים הנפוצות, כן? זאת אומרת, אם אנחנו נסתכל עכשיו על האינטגרל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של הדבר הזה, אז אנחנו נראה שאם אני קוטם את ההתפלגות הזאת, אני לא יודע מה, כן? ב100, ב200, ב1000, כן? אתם תקבלו כל פעם יותר, אבל אתם תקבלו את רוב המסה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: את רוב מסת ההתפלגות, זאת אומרת רוב המילים יהיו בין האיקס הראשונים, אוקיי? אבל זה לא יורד אקספוננציאלית, זה לא כמו התפלגות נורמלית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאתם אומרים, טוב, כמה סטיות תקן מהתוחלת אני כבר יכול להזניח, כבר כמעט אין שם שום מסה. לא, זה זנב כבד. כלומר, אומנם כל מילה נדירה בפני עצמה מופיעה מעט פעמים, אבל כל המילים הנדירות ביחד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מופיעות די הרבה פעמים. כלומר, אני לא באמת יכול להתעלם מהמקרה הזה של מילים נדירות. אז מצד אחד, יש לי מעט מילים נפוצות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מצד שני, אני כל הזמן אמשיך לראות מילים נדירות, וכולל מילים שלא ראיתי בעבר, כן? אפילו אם יש לי קורפוס מאוד גדול.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה נכון לגבי מילים וזה נכון לגבי צירופי מילים וביטויים ומבנים תחביריים והרבה מאוד תופעות אחרות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר, מישהו מכם יצא לו לשמוע את המושג הזה, פאוור לוד דיסטריביושן? כן, התפלגות חוק חזקה, באיזה הקשרים?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אה... זוכרים? לא? אוקיי. סתם בפיזיקה אולי? יש כאן תלמידי פיזיקה? אוקיי, טוב, סבבה. בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז בעצם מה שאנחנו רואים, לא רק במילים אלא גם בתחביר, שיש לנו מצד אחד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חוקים שהם חוקים מרכזיים, דומיננטיים, נפוצים, ויש עוד המון המון חוקים הרבה יותר ספציפיים והרבה יותר נדירים. בוא ניקח דוגמה, אוקיי? הטיית מילים באנגלית, הטיית זמן עבר באנגלית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו רואים שבעצם עבור אי די,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון? מה שנקרא אי די או איי אי די או די, נכון? מה שנקרא רגולר ורבס, נכון? כמו ווק ווק, ג'אמפ ג'אמפ וכן הלאה, יש המון דוגמאות לזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל יש גם מקרים אחרים שהם לא נופלים לקטגוריה הזאת, גם בהם יש, כן, חוקיות מסוימת, כן? כמו למשל, אני יודע מה, סיט,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ופין, פין, ופיט, פיט, נכון? וכל מיני מילים שהן כאלה שלוש אותיות כאלה עם ואול באמצע, שהם בגדול לא נוטו, כאילו מה שנקרא נאל דריווישן, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הטיה שלא משנה כלום, אבל גם יש דברים לא רגולריים יותר נדירים, וגם בהם יש חוקיות מסוימת, אבל גם להם יש יוצאים מן הכלל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. בואו ניתן כמה דוגמאות לכללים דקדוקיים קצת פחות נפוצים באנגלית, ואסביר לכם למה אני מתכוון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נגיד למשל, בגדול, אם יש לכם פועל באנגלית, נכון? בהווה, אתם רוצים לשלול אותו, אז אתם צריכים להוסיף נוט אחרי הפועל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון? כמו למשל, כן, סליחה. אתם לא להוסיף אחרי הפועל, אלא להוסיף דידנט או דונט או דזנט, כן? תלוי בזמן ובמין.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כדי לשלול אותו, נכון? כמו למשל, אני הלכתי, אני לא הלכתי, כן? או כן, אני הלכתי, או הוא הלך, הוא לא הלך וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מסתבר שלפחות בלהגים מסוימים של אנגלית, אני לא יודע, זה בסדר, כן? אפשר להגיד גם אני לא יודע.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל גם איי האבנט קלו או איי האב נוט קלו הוא בסדר, אבל נגיד איי האב נוט לוק, כלומר איי דידנט האב לוק, הוא לא עובד. יש כאן דוברי אנגלית ילידיים במקרה בינינו?
Amit Levonai: כן, אז מה אתה אומר, עמית? זה נשמע רע. זה לא נשמע טוב. נשמע רע, נכון. מה אתה חושב על הבנט קלו?
Amit Levonai: זה מדויק, אבל זה לא עובד. אולי. כן, זה יעבוד, אבל אז זה בעצם כבר כ...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? לא משנה. בקיצור, משהו נורא ספציפי. ניקח משהו אחר, קצת יותר נפוץ, אבל עדיין, כלומר אני מתכוון לעתיד, סליחה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ו... אז זה בעתיד, אבל אותו טנס, נכון? אותו הטייה של פועל, הוא לא הביתה ב17.00, הכוונה היא לא שאני מדבר על 17.00 אחר הצהריים היום,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון? שבו הוא לא יהיה. אני מתכוון באופן שגרתי, מה שנקרא הביצ'וול, הוא לא יבוא הביתה ב17:00, זה מה שאני צריך להגיד אם אני מתכוון להיום.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לרמוז שזה היום. דוגמה נוספת, ריבר טמס, לעומת מיסיסיפי ריבר. אז יש נהרות שבהן המילה מופיעה, השם מופיע אחרי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ויש כאלה שזה מופיע לפני, ולפעמים יש כאלה שעובד גם זה וגם זה. למה? כנראה שיש גם הבדלים בריטיים מול אמריקאים. זהו, זה לא עניין של ניב כלשהו, של בריטים נגד אמריקאים?
Amit Levonai: נראה לי שבאמריקה כל הנערות הן קודם השם של הנער ואז נער. אוקיי, אבל הבריטים לפחות לא יקראו, לדעתי, אולי האמריקאים...
Amit Levonai: אתה אומר האמריקאים יקראו גם לריבר טיימס, יקראו לו טיימס ריבר? לדעתי כן, לי זה נשמע מוזר להגיד ריבר טיימס.
Amit Levonai: וואלה, אוקיי. אז אני אבדוק את זה, יכול להיות שזה בריטי. אני עשיתי את הפוסטדוק שלי בסקוטלנד, אז יכול להיות שמשם אני לקחתי את הדוגמה הזאת והיא קצת מוטה לזה, אבל אני אבדוק את זה, תודה, לאהרון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בקיצור, כפי שאתם רואים, יש כללים מאוד ספציפיים ויש כאלה מאוד כלליים. המכונה שצריכה לכתוב שפה פלואנט, שפה קולחת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: צריכה ללמוד גם את אלה וגם את אלה. לחלק מהם יהיה לה המון המון דוגמאות, ולאחרות יהיה לה הרבה פחות, וצריך להבין בדיוק את החוקיות הדי מורכבת. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עוד הערה חשובה לי לומר מככה נקודת המבט של בן אדם שחוקר שפה, זה שלמרות שהפוקוס של הקורס הזה הולך להיות יותר טכנולוגי, אלגוריתמי, חשוב לי לומר שהעיסוק בשפה הוא לא...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זאת אומרת, אי אפשר לצמצם אותו אך ורק לזה. בדיוק בגלל ששפה נתפסת על ידי רבים כאיזשהו ראי לאינטליגנציה או ראי למיינד האנושי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם השאלה איך ממדלים שפה ואיך בונים מערכות שמפגינות יכולות שפתיות ומתי מגדירים שלמערכת מסוימת יש יכולת שפתית מספקת או לא, אלה לא שאלות טכניות בלבד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אלה גם שאלות שמעידות על גישה אינטלקטואלית מסוימת, כן? וסתם לתת כאן שתי דוגמאות על קצה המזלג, שני אנשים שהם מאבות התחום, נועם חומסקי הבלשן ואיש תיאוריה של מדעי המחשב בעצם,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אולי למדתם עליו גם מי שלקח חישוביות. וקלוד שנון, איש מהנדס וממציא תורת האינפורמציה, שניים מהאינטלקטואלים הבולטים של המאה ה20,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם הנה שני ציטוטים שלהם. אחד של חומסקי מ69,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי? כלומר, הוא לא כל כך קונה את זה שסטטיסטיקה זה חלק מרכזי, אולי זו דרך לבנות טכנולוגיה, אבל הוא בטח לא חושב שזה איזשהו משהו שיש לו משמעות מבחינת תיאוריה לשונית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: קלוד צ'נון כותב, כלומר, קלוד שרון,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מגיעים לגישה מאוד אחרת ודווקא מאוד מדגיש את העניין הזה של הידע העצום שיש לנו כדוברי שפה שמאפשר לנו להשלים משפטים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לתקן טעויות, להשלים אפילו משפטים של אחרים וכן הלאה. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עדיין בתחום ההקדמה השפתית, גם אני רציתי לציין שפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לרוב כשמדברים על ניתוח שפה, מדברים על... וכנ"ל גם בקורס הזה, מדברים על כמה... בעצם על שכבות שונות של ניתוח, כן? מדברים על זה ששפה בעצם פועלת בכמה רבדים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: באופן סימולטני, אבל הרבה פעמים האנליזה שלנו היא אנליזה שמוגבלת לשכבה אחת מסוימת. אז למשל, יש לנו את השכבה ממש של המילים עצמן,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ששם אנחנו לפעמים מדברים ואנחנו נדבר על תכונות כמו הפרטוספיץ' שלהם, כן? חלק הדיבר, האם זה מיידע או פועל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או תואר השם או שם עצם וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו נדבר על הנטיות, באנגלית יש פחות נטיות, נטיות של מילים, אבל בעברית יש הרבה יותר, נכון? שמע, שמע, שמעתי, שמע, השמיע,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שזה כבר הטיה מסוג אחר, כן, והשתמע וכן הלאה. אנחנו נדבר על מובנים של מילים, סימפל יכול להיות משהו שיש לו מעט חלקים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמו כאן, אבל זה גם יכול להיות, אבל סימפל זה גם יכול להיות משהו כמו פשוט, שקל לפתור אותו, משהו כזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סנטנס יכול להיות משפט וגם יכול להיות גזר דין וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. אז זה ברמת המילים. אבל אנחנו נדבר לא רק על שכבות של ניתוח של משפט, של ניתוח של מילים בודדות, אלא גם של משפט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: דברים שיזכירו לכם אולי את מי שעוד זוכר את שיעורי לשון, אבל קצת שונה. כל מיני עצים כאלה שנבנה על גבי המילים כדי להדגים איך נראה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: איך המילים מתחברות ביחד, קשר בין משפטים, כן? נגיד קשר של קונטרסט, של ניגוד. ומבנה גם ברמה של טקסטים שלמים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ופסקאות, בעצם אנחנו מדברים ממש על כל הרמות. לפעמים באנליזה מסוימת כמובן מתמקדים בחלק מהרמות, אבל ככלל כולן פועלות איכשהו ביחד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז לסיכום ההקדמה, זאת רשימת הנושאים בעצם בגדול שנדבר עליה בקורס. אנחנו נדבר כמובן על מודלים שפהיים, על מודלי שפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מסוגים שונים. אנחנו נדבר על קלאסיפיקציה של מסמכים או באופן כללי קלאסיפיקציה של טקסטים, חלוקה של טקסטים לקטגוריות נתונות. נדבר על ניתוח לשוני,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם מהסוג של מילים בודדות, חלקי דיבר של מילים בודדות וגם מבנה תחבירי שבעצם ייתן לנו דוגמה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של ניתוח ברמת משפט ולא מילה בודדת. נדבר על סנטימנט אנליסיס, כלומר לזהות מה הסנטימנט שטקסט מביע, אם הוא אוהד, אם הוא שלילי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם הוא תומך, אם הוא מסתייג וכן הלאה. על אנליזה סמנטית קצת ועל אינפורמיישן אקסטרקשן שהזכרנו קודם ועל תרגום מכונה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מבחינת המת'דס, השיטות, אנחנו נסקור מגוון גדול של שיטות, רובן ככולן שיטות סטטיסטיות ובגלל זה גם באמת
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הוספנו את איימל כדרישת קדם לקורס, אבל אלה שיטות שרבות מהן לא יהיו אלו שלמדתם באיימל לדעתי, אלא שיטות אחרות, חלקן גם פניו, אז יהיה גם וגם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יהיה לנו פה בליסטיק מודלים, מודלים הסתברותיים, שיטות גנרטיביות ודיסקרימיטיביות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נאיב בייס, לוג ליניאר מודלס, יהיה לנו רשתות נוירונים של פיד פורוורד נטוורקס ורקורנט נוירול נטוורקס וגם טרנספורמרים לקראת הסוף.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נדבר על מודלים מרקובים, מודלים מרקובים חבויים, קונדישיונל רנדום פילדס, על סטרקטור פרדיקשן, כלומר לעשות פרדיקציה למבנה שלם ולא רק ללייבל בודד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ועל כל הנושאים האלה אנחנו נעמיק, אני רק ככה זורק את המושגים למקרה שחלקכם כבר מוכרים לכם מקורסים קודמים. מבחינת טקסטבוקס, התחום הזה משתנה כל הזמן, אז קצת קשה למצוא טקסטבוק שהוא
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ממש מעודכן, הכי קרוב לזה, זה טקסטבוק שנמצא פשוט במצב טיוטה די תמידי האמת וכל הזמן מתעדכן, שזה בעצם ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של ספר שנמצא בספרייה, אבל בספרייה יש רק את הסקנד אדישן, והסקנד אדישן הוא זמין באתר שלו, אז תכלס עדיף להסתכל עליו, כן? ספר של דן ז'ורבסקי וג'יימס מרטין.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: חוץ מזה, עוד ספר טקסט בוק טוב להקדמה, גם הוא נמצא, אני לא בטוח אם הוא נמצא בספרייה, אני חושב שכן. אני אוודא את זה האמת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני חושב שיש לי עותק שלו, אם מישהו מתעניין. ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכמובן הרבה פעמים במהלך הקורס, זה קורס כבר שנה ג' או תארים מתקדמים, אני הרבה פעמים במהלך הקורס אפנה אתכם למאמרים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה לא תהיה קריאת חובה, כן? בגדול החומר של הקורס שיופיע בבחינה זה החומר שאני אלמד בכיתה, כן? אבל אני בהחלט מציע וממליץ, אתם כבר בשלב מתקדם בלימודים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם להיכנס לפחות למאמרים שמעניינים אתכם, להעמיק בדברים, להבין קצת יותר את ההקשר, ואני בעצם אנסה בקורס הזה לספק לכם כלים שיאפשרו לכם, אני חושב, להבין
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לפחות ברמת הרעיון, את המאמרים, כולל החדשים בתחום, ובעצם ריכוז של המאמרים שמתפרסמים בפורומים של אנאלפי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה האי.סי.אל אנתולוג'י, שזה אתר שבו כל המאמרים זמינים בחינם, באופן פתוח, אז זה מקום אחד טוב לחפש בו. הוא מחולק בגדול לפי פורומים של הפרסום, אז אלה הפורומים המובילים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל גם יש הרבה אחרים. יש עוד לא מעט מאמרים, אם אתם רוצים לחפש נושאים שמעניינים אתכם שמופיעים בכנסים של משין לרנינג, כמו אייקליר, אייסיאםאל, נויריפס.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז גם שווה לחפש שם. וכמובן כדאי לכם להכיר, אם עוד לא הכרתם, מנועי חיפוש וארכייב, במות פרסום פתוחות של...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של מאמרים מדעיים באופן כללי, שמאפשר לכם חיפוש, ויש שם באמת מגוון אדיר של עבודה בהרבה מאוד תחומים, שזה גוגל סקולר, סימנטק סקולר, ארכייב. אז מי שלא מכיר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: את אחד או יותר מהאתרים האלה, נראה לי זה משהו שכל אדם שעוסק במדע היום שווה להיכנס וטיפה לשחק עם זה. אוקיי, תודות לכמה מעמיתיי ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לקחתי מהם שקפים. אז כן, שרון גולדווטר, ניתן שניידר, ריי מוני, יואב ארצי, דן צ'רבסקי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וזהו, אז זה בעצם מה שרציתי להגיד בנושא ההקדמה לקורס, ככה לתת איזושהי סקירה. אז יש למישהו שאלות לגבי ההקדמה? בשעה הבאה אנחנו כבר...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נתחיל להיכנס ממש לחומר עצמו. אוקיי, מצוין. אז בוא נחזור ככה שתי דקות לפני אחת, לפני שתיים, סליחה, ונמשיך.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, ממשיכים.
Tal Avinir: בסדר. אפשר שאלה קטנה לפני שהם ממשיכים? כן.
Tal Avinir: עכשיו בעצם, זה בעצם השעה השלישית שלנו, שזה התרגול? כי פשוט בשנתון מופיע ש... כן, מופיע שזה תרגול, זו הייתה טעות, ביקשתי שיתקנו, לא תיקנו את זה עדיין?
Tal Avinir: לא, כרגע מה שמופיע שם זה שיש תרגול בין שתיים לשתיים ארבעים וחמש. ומי מופיע כמורה? איתן יהושע וגנר. כן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני לא יודע מה הניע אותם לעשות את הצעד הזה, אבל זה... לעשות בנים זה טעות. אז מה שיקרה בדרך כלל זה שפשוט יהיה לנו שלוש שעות ברצף? כן. אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נכון. טוב, אז נתחיל לדבר על מודלי שפה, אבל נתחיל מהבסיס, מה שנקרא מודלי שפה מרקובי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז דבר ראשון, מה זה מודל שפה? מודל שפה בעצם זה מכניזם הסתברותי לייצר טקסט, כן? לחולל טקסט או...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: באופן אולי קצת יותר פורמלי ומדויק, זה מודל הסתברותי שמגדיר התפלגות על פני טקסטים, על פני מחוזות סופיות מעל איזשהו א' ב'.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הבעיה של בעצם מציאת או שיערוך מודל הסתברותי של טקסטים בשפה נתונה, ספציפית באנגלית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם נחקר לראשונה על ידי אותו קלוד שנון, שאבי תורת האינפורמציה שהזכרתי בשעה הקודמת, במאמר מאוד מעניין וקריא, האמת, אם מעניין אתכם לקרוא,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של 1951, שבעצם בו הוא חקר באיזה מידה המילה הבאה היא ניתן לחזות אותה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מתוך המילים שקדמו לה, כן? או מילה או אותיות או משהו בסגנון הזה. ובעצם הדרך,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לגשת לבעיה הזאת, להבין כמה זה פרדיקטבול, זה לנסות לנסח איזשהו מודל הסתברותי, לאמוד על איזשהו מודל הסתברותי של השפה, ואז בעצם לראות כמה מידע או כמה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מוסר ודאות יש לגבי זהות המילה הבאה, בהינתן שאנחנו רואים את המילים שלפניה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: במאמר הזה הוא הציג בעצם איזשהו ניסוי מחשבתי של הימים קראו לו השלמנס גיים על שמו. זה לא משחק אמיתי, כן? זה איזשהו יותר כמו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ניסוי מחשבתי כזה שבעצם אומר ככה, בוא נגיד עכשיו שאתם מתבקשים לחזות איזשהו משפט שאתם לא יודעים מה, אוקיי? אז אתם לא יודעים מה המשפט הזה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שאתם יכולים לעשות בכל שלב זה פשוט לנחש את האות הבא. אז בהתחלה עומדת מולכם המחרוזת הריקה, אוקיי? המחרוזת הריקה, ואתם חוזים שהאות הראשונה בה נגיד היא טי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי? אז אם הייתם במחרוזת הזאת, זה אומר שהצלחתם. נכון? אבל אם המשפט היה אז זה אומר שלא הצלחתם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכנ"ל לגבי פולי שטרוד, בת לסון דה שבי וכן הלאה. אוקיי, עכשיו המשחק עובד ככה, אם הצלחתם, אני אומר לכם שהצלחתם. אם לא הצלחתם, אני אומר לכם מה האות האמיתית שהייתה שם.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר? אז כאן מופיע קו שכאילו אומר הצלחתם בעצם, הפרדיקציה שלכם נכונה, זה כל האינפורמציה שקיבלתם, אין לי מה להוסיף, זה נכון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכאן זה אומר שנתתי לכם את האות הנכונה. ועכשיו חוזר חלילה, אם יש לכם את אר, סליחה, או את טי, עכשיו אתם חוזרים מהאות הבאה. שוב, אותו דבר, אני או אומר לכם מה נכון, נגיד אם חזיתם
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: משהו שהוא לא אי אחרי האר, אני אומר לכם, וזה המשפט, אז אני אומר לכם שזה אי. אם ניחשתם אחרי הטי אייץ' וזה באמת אייץ', אז שוב צדקתם וכן הלאה. ועכשיו, מה הרעיון כאן? הרעיון הוא
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שבעצם יש כאן שני רעיונות, כן? אז רעיון אחד אומר שבגלל שהשפה, בעצם בגלל שאתם יודעים שפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז בעצם גם יש לכם גישה לגבי הרגולריות הסטטיסטית שלה. והמידע הזה לגבי הרגולריות הסטטיסטית עוזר לכם, בעצם בעזרתו אתם מסוגלים לנחש
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בהסתברות שהיא הרבה יותר מאשר ההסתברות של סתם, אם זה היה איזושהי מחוזת אקראית, מה היה האות הבא בהינתן הפריפיקס, והשאלה היא כמה טוב ניתן לעשות את זה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עכשיו, הוא התעניין בזה מנקודת המבט של קידוד, אוקיי? מה שנקרא קידוד מקור. יש כאן אנשים שלקחו קורס כותרות האינפורמציה? כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טוב, כן, אוקיי. קידוד מקור, או גם, זה נכון, גם במקרה של קידוד דורות זה רלוונטי, אבל נגיד נסתכל על קידוד מקור, כלומר, יש לכם, מישהו עכשיו רוצה לשדר שדר. כן, מישהו רוצה לשדר אליכם שדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אתם לא יודעים מה השדר הזה וגם... כן, אז אתם לא יודעים מה השדר הזה ובעצם השאלה היא איך הוא יכול להעביר לכם כמה שפחות ביטים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ושבכל זאת אתם תדעו לפענח במה מדובר, כן? בלי שגיאה. נגיד אפילו, נגיד בלי שגיאה במקרה האידיאלי. אז בעצם השאלה הזאת של מה הרגולריות הסטטיסטית של שפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה בעצם דרך אחרת לשאול את זה, זה השאלה איך אני יכול לקודד שפה באופן אופטימלי למה הדברים האלה קשורים, אז בוא נחשוב על זה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם הייתה לי איזושהי דרך, באמת איזשהו מודל קידום טוב, כן? מודל טוב של השפה, מודל פרדיקטיבי טוב, אז כל מה שהייתי צריך לשדר לכם זה שבהתחלה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שאתם מנחשים כבר הוא נכון, כן? זה רק כאילו, רק להביא את הביט הזה. מה שאתם חושבים זה נכון, גם אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה נכון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: גם אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה נכון, גם אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה נכון, אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה לא נכון, זה אר, כן? אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה לא נכון, זה או, אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה לא נכון, זה גם או, אחרי זה מה שאתם חושבים זה נכון,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכן הלאה וכן הלאה, ובסטרינג הזה, בהנחה שאני מקודד את זה לפי מודל הקידוד שלכם, יש בדיוק את אותו מידע כמו בסטרינג הזה, נכון?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כי אתם תדעו לפענח בדיוק בעזרת המודל הפרדיקטיבי שלכם. כי אמרתי לכם איפה אתם צודקים ואיפה אתם טועים, וכשאתם טועים, מה הייתם צריכים לבקש?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל בסטרינג הזה יש הרבה פחות, לקודד אותו ייקח לי הרבה פחות, נכון? כי אני לא צריך, בכל המקרים שבהם כתוב קו, אני לא צריך להעביר את האות, מספיק לי להעביר את זה שצדקתם, כן? שדר יותר עני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רק ביט אחד במקום, לא יודע, לוג של גודל אוצר המילים. וככל שהיכולת, עכשיו אם היכולת הפרדיקטיבית שלכם גרועה, אוקיי? אתם פרדיקטורים גרועים, מה יקרה?
Amit Levonai: אתה תצטרך לשלוח הרבה יותר ביטים פשוט, הרבה פחות מידע. בדיוק, אני עדיין אהיה מחויב.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם זה המשחק, כן? לעיקרון שאתם צריכים לפענח את השדר בדיוק. אבל כדי להשיג את זה, אני איאלץ לשלוח את כל האותיות, נכון? כי לא צדקתם בשום דבר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? בעצמכם. אבל ככל שהמודל הפרדיקטיבי שלכם יותר טוב, ככה אני צריך לשלוח פחות. בגלל זה הבעיות האלה הן מאוד מאוד קשורות, ואנחנו נראה שהרבה מהתוצאות בתחום הזה של מודל שפה, אפשר להבין אותם או דרך הפרספקטיבה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של דחיסה, כן? או דרך הפרספקטיבה של פרדיקציה של מהי המילה הבאה, אוקיי? או מה ההסתברות של ה... יש קשר הדוק בין הדברים. טוב.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר. אז המשחק של שנון בעצם מאפשר לנו, או השערוך של מודל שינסה לפתור את המשחק של שנון, עוזר לנו לשערך מה מידת האנטרדיקטביליטי של שפה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, בעצם האנפרדיקטביליטי זה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה בעצם היכולת הכי טובה כאילו לקודד את זה, היכולת התיאורטית איכשהו הכי טובה, זה אפשר להגיד שמה שעדיין האי ודאות שנשאר אפילו לפרדיקטור הטוב ביותר שיש,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה מידת אי הוודאות האמיתית של השפה. ובעצם... ובעצם זה הפרספקטיבה ששאלון הסתכל עליה. האם מחשבים יכולים לעשות אותו דבר? אז...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולמה זאת בכלל שאלה מעניינת? אז האם הם יכולים לעשות? אז אנחנו נראה, זה בדיוק התחום הזה של מודל שפה. האם זאת שאלה מעניינת? על פניו אולי כן, זאת אומרת אולי לא בדיוק ברור לנו בינתיים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למה שנרצה כזה דבר, אבל לכל הפחות זה נראה כמו איזשהו בנצ'מרק, כמו איזושהי דרך מעניינת לבדוק טכנולוגיה שפתית, כן? האם...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם אם יש לנו מודל שפה, אנחנו אומרים, אם יש לי פרדיקטור טוב של שפה, חזקה עליו שהוא מייצג איזשהו ידע אמיתי על השפה. נכון? כי אם לא היה לו ידע אמיתי על השפה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז למה שהוא יצליח לנחש בצורה משמעותית יותר טובה מאשר סתם ניחושים אקראיים. אוקיי? אז בעצם, אתם רואים כאן, יש כאן איזשהו שיפט בין כאילו הגול הטכני,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: להיות מסוגל לחזות, לבין איזשהו משהו יותר שקשור להבנה שאומר נראה לי שכדי לחזות משהו בצורה מספיק טובה, אני לפחות בחלק מהמקרים צריך קצת להבין מה הולך.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אחרת אני לא כל כך אצליח להבין מה המילה הבאה, ולכן לבנות מערכת שיודעת לחזות מה המילה הבאה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה דרך טובה אולי לפתח טכנולוגיה שפתית, כי על הדרך אני אבנה מערכות שיודעות להבין כל מיני דברים, כי אחרת הם יקשו. אתם מבינים בערך את הרציונל פה של ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, להפוך את הבעיה הערטילאית הזאת של מה זה להבין, סך הכול בעיה מאוד קונקרטית. צריך לחזות או שצדקתי או שטעיתי, אפשר למדוד את זה, אוקיי? עכשיו יותר... כל הדברים יותר ברורים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר, אבל מעבר לזה עולה השאלה האם גם יש לזה איזשהו ערך, סליחה, האם יש לזה גם איזושהי תועלת בזכות עצמה? זאת אומרת, האם היכולת לחזות מהי המילה הבאה או מה ההסתברות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של מחוזות יש גם ערך בפני עצמה. אז אני דבר ראשון אומר שיש לזה ערך כמודל פסיפולינגוויסטי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן? אז אם היינו עכשיו בקורס יותר קוגניטיבי, היינו מדברים על זה שאולי על זה שגם בבני אדם יש בעצם באיזשהו מובן מתחזקים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: פרדיקציות לגבי מהי המילה הבאה והם רגישים, אפשר לראות מתי הפרדיקציות האלה נסתרו, כלומר, הם קיבלו שדר שהוא...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שנראה להם לא סביר, כן? בהינתן הפרדיקציות שלהם, מתי לא. אז יש ערך למודל היספה גם כאיזשהו מודל קוגניטיבי. אבל בוא נעזוב את זה שנייה בצד ונשאל טכנולוגית, האם יש איזשהו ערך במודל השפה לכשעצמו?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, אז לפני שנראה את ה... בעצם נענה על השאלה הזאת, נגדיר את הקצת נוטציה. אז אנחנו בגדול, כשאנחנו מדברים על מודלי שפה, אנחנו פשוט
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נסתכל על זה כהסתברות של טקסט, הסתברות של רצף.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של מחרוזת, של רצף טוקנס. הטוקנס האלה יכולים להיות אותיות או מילים או רווחים או סימנים, לא ממש חשוב מה, אבל הנקודה היא שיש לנו איזשהו אוצר מילים נתון, ידוע ו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, סופי, ויש לנו מחוזות על פני אוצר המילים הזה, אנחנו באופן עקרוני יכולים להסתכל על כל מחוזת סופית מעל אוצר המילים הזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואנחנו רוצים להגדיר התפלגות משותפת. בעצם מודל שפה פורמלית הוא פשוט התפלגות משותפת על פני כל המחוזות הסופיות מעל אוצר המילים הנתון. באופן שקול אפשר, נכון לפי כלל השרשרת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: במקום להגדיר התפלגות משותפת, ניתן גם פשוט להגדיר הסתדרות של המילה הבאה, נכון בהינתן הקודמות. כי הסתדרות של מילה, כן, התפלגות משותפת של
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כ מילים, זה פשוט ההסתברות של הראשונה כפול ההסתברות של השנייה בהינתן הראשונה, כפול ההסתברות של השלישית בהינתן שתי הראשונות, הרביעית בהינתן שלוש הראשונות וכן הלאה. זוכרים את הכלל הזה? כלל השורשרת מהסתברות?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: טובת ההסתברות, אוקיי, מי שלא זוכר, מציע לכם לעבור על החומר מטובת ההסתברות, זה אחת התוצאות או ההגדרות, כן, זה איזושהי מסקנה מיידית מההגדרה של התפלגות מותנה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי. ובאמת אפשר לעבור בין הדברים. אז אם יש לנו את ההתפלגות המשותפת, אז אני יכול לחשב את ההתפלגויות המותנות, נכון? אני יכול לדעת מה ההסתדרות של טוקן בהינתן
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אין מינוס אחד הטוקנים הקודמים, אם אני מסתכל על ההתפלגות המשותפת של כל המחרוזת, כל הטוקנס, לחלק להסתברות של אין מינוס אחד הראשונים, נכון? זה לפי ההגדרה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: פשוט ההסתברות המותנה שלה אין בהינתן הקודמים, אז אני יכול לעבור בין... שוב, אני מניח שאין לנו אפסים כרגע, אפסים זה צרה ונדבר עליה בהמשך. נגיד שאין לנו הסתברויות שהן אפס,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז קל לחלק ואין שום בעיה ואני יכול באמצעות המשותפת להגדיר את המותנה, ובאמצעות המותנה אני יכול להגדיר את המשותפת לפי כלל השרשרת, נכון? המכפלה על ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: על ההתפלגות של טוקן בהינתן הקודמים. אוקיי, אז קל לעבור בין אחד לשני ובאמת בגלל זה לפעמים מגדירים את זה ככה, לפעמים מגדירים את זה ככה, אבל זה לא משנה. יהיה לנו קל לעבור בין אחד לשני וזה רק עניין טכני.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רגע, מישהו שאל אותי שאלה. אתם יכולים גם באמת לשאול, פשוט לא לעשות אנמיות, סיכוי יותר גבוה שאני זה. אז אלון שואל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כשאתה אומר טוקן, אתה מתכוון למילה או אות? אוקיי, אז שאלה מצוינת. זה יהיה תלוי בהקשר. זאת אומרת, אנחנו תמיד... כרגע זה נגיד מילים, אוקיי? אבל באותה מידה זה יכול להיות רצפי מילים, אותיות, סימנים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כל דבר אחר, כן? כל מה שמשנה זה שאוצר המילים ידוע מראש. כלומר, אני מראש יודע מה נחשב טוקן ומה לא, אוקיי? ומה נחשב רצף של טוקנס שאפשר לחלק אותו לחתיכות, בסדר?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אממ, טוב.אחלה.סיכום.כן. אז אממאפליקציה אחת.ספיץ' רקומיישן. כן? אתם ודאי מכירים. אה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ספיץ' טו טקסט, נכון? אודיו אין, טקסט אאוט. יש מכם שמשתמשים בכאלה דברים גם? אתם מדברים, מכתיבים למחשב או לטלפון או משהו והוא כותב?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, טכנולוגיה מאוד פופולרית בחוגים מסוימים. וכן, משהו שכבר קיים הרבה מאוד שנים, רמות הולכות ומשתפרות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, לפני כמה שנים הסטייט אוף די ארט היה באנגלית, היה משהו כמו אחוז מאוד קטן, אם זה אוצר מילים סגור, מין קצב של הכתבה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אם זה אוצר מינים פתוח קצב של הכתבה, זה היה קצת צד הגודל יותר, ואם זה להקליט מהטלוויזיה, אז גם יותר מזה. הדברים האלה הולכים ומשתפרים, אז כמובן תלוי באיך בדיוק אתם מחשבים, באיזה סטינג וכולי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל בגדול גם שם יש כמובן רמות שונות בתלות ברעש, בתלות בכמה ברור, האם מדובר בקול של קריין רהוט או של מישהו שמדבר במבטא כבד וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עכשיו, למה שאני צריך מודלי שפה בסיפור הזה? אז מסתבר שבמשך הרבה מאוד שנים מודלי שפה, אפילו כשמודלי השפה היו עוד הרבה יותר פרימיטיביים מאלה של היום, הם כבר היו שימושיים לספיץ' וקוגנישן. ולמה?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז מסתבר שלזהות טקסט או שפה כשאתם הולכים ומנסים לעשות לה טרנסקריפציה, מסתבר שזה סיפור די מסובך, בגלל שאנחנו לא הוגים את ההגאים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ברצף כזה תחום, כן? אנחנו לא הוגים איזשהו הגה אחד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואז עוברים להגה הבא ואז כל מה שצריך זה לזהות את הגבולות שלהם ואתם יודעים והכל ככה נקי ומסודר. אם אתם טיפה התעסקתם בעבר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בספיץ', בסיגנל של דיבור, אתם יודעים שיש שם כל מיני דברים שונים ומשונים, יש דברים של קוארטיקולציה, של דברים נשמעים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הגאים כשהם ביחד נהגים אחרת מאשר כל אחד מהם בנפרד, אתם יודעים שאין הפרדה טמפורלית, שהדברים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הסוף של האחד מתחיל, הוא הרבה פעמים על ההתחלה של השני, כל מיני דברים, וזה בלגן.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שזה אומר זה שכשאתם תנסו לפענח את סיגנל הקול, בהחלט יכול להיות שאם אני אגיד לכם אולי נהיה רעש וכולי, אתם תקבלו סיגנל שהדבר שהוא הכי דומה לו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה "רק נייס ביץ'". או אם אני אגיד לכם "איי אייטד צ'רי", אולי הדרך הכי טובה, כאילו הסיגנל, הסטרינג הכי טוב שמתאים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לרצף הצלילים הזה לכשעצמו, זה איי, אייט, אה, ג'רי נגיד, או סתם דוגמאות טיפשיות. אבל תודות ללנגוויג' מודל, יש לנו ישועה. נכון? בגלל שהלנגוויג' מודל יגיד לנו, תראו,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני לא יודע הרבה על שפה, אוקיי? אבל ממה שאני יודע, זה משפט הרבה הרבה פחות סביר באנגלית מאשר... אוקיי? ואז אני אומר, טוב,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז אם אני אכניס גם את המידע הזה שיש לי, שהוא לא כל כך מוצלח, לא בגלל שהוא... לא בגלל שהסיגנל האודיטורי...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הסיגנל, כן, הסיגנל האקוסטי שלי לא דומה לרקניס ביץ', הוא דומה לרקניס ביץ', אלא פשוט כי מי הלך להגיד רקניס ביץ', אז אני אולי אדע להבין שזה רקניס ביץ'.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולפעמים קוראים לזה ה'נויזי צ'אנל מודל', כן? המודל לערוץ הרועש. כי בעצם דרך אחת להמשיג את זה, זה להגיד אוקיי, יש לי איזשהו מודל הסתברותי
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: של ההסתברות של... של בעצם ההסתברות המשותפת של הסיגנל האקוסטי והסיגנל הטקסטואלי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ומה שאני רוצה למצוא זה בהינתן הסיגנל האקוסטי, איי, בהינתן האודיו, אני רוצה להבין מה הטקסט הסביר ביותר. אני רוצה לחפש את הארגמקס של פי דאבליו בהינתן איי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל את הארג מקס של פי של דאבליו בהינתן איי, אני יכול לכתוב מחוק בייס, כפי של איי בהינתן דאבליו כפול פי של דאבליו חלקי פי של איי. פי של איי הוא קבוע, הוא לא תלוי בדאבליו, אז
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה אותו דבר כמו למקסם את המונה, כלומר את פי של איי בהינתן דבליו ואת פי של דבליו. כלומר, אם יש לי מודל שפה, אני יכול למשקל את ה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ההיפוטזות השונות, את הדאבליוים השונים, לפי פי של אין בהינתן דאבליו, כלומר לפי ההסתברות ההפוכה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וככה לתת בוסט לדברים כמו רקורנייס ביץ' ולהעניש דברים כמו רקורנייס ביץ'. אוקיי? אז איך זה יראה? נגיד למשל אני מקבל...
Amit Levonai: למה מלכתחילה זה מודל הסתברותי שאנחנו מדברים על אודיו? הרי זה לא בהכרח... זה חד משמעי, כלומר זה חד חד ערכי לרוב. כן, אז תראה, אז...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז הסתברות, כן, זאת שאלה טובה. בעצם גם כשאתה מדבר על שפה, כן, באופן כללי, נגיד לנסות לחזות את ה... אתה יודע, לנסות לחזות את המילה הבאה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם, ככלל אנחנו לא באמת מניחים שאנשים מדברים שפה באיזשהו תהליך סטוכסטי, נכון? שבו הם כל פעם מגרילים איזושהי התפלגות בהינתן הקודמות, מהי המילה הבאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הנקודה היא שלך יש... בעצם כאן הרבה פעמים במודלי שפה ההסתברות לא מייצגת את זה שהעולם הוא סטוכסטי בהכרח,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אלא מייצגת את אי הוודאות שלנו בקשר למצבו של העולם. אוקיי? אז בעצם אתה אומר אני לא יודע אם עכשיו שמעתי משהו, אוקיי? אני לא יודע מה הוא. אני חושב, יש לי כל מיני אפשרויות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אולי שמעתי, למעשה זה הדבר שהכי נראה לי סביר, בהינתן מה ששמעתי, שהוא הטקסט הנכון.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אה, אבל אולי זה the station signs are in deep in English. זה נגיד כאילו לקחתי את הלוג הסתברות. כן? סתם דוגמה, כן? דוגמה מוצאת. אבל אולי זה the station signs are in deep into English.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עכשיו, כל פעם ההסתברות יורדת קצת, כן? אז כאילו זה הופך להיות דברים פחות ופחות סבירים. אבל מה מודל השפה יגיד לי? מודל השפה אולי בשאיפה יגיד לי שמתוך כל מה שכתוב כאן זה הכי סביר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כלומר, לפני שראיתי את האודיו, אפריורית, מה שהכי סביר,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סליחה, זה יותר סביר שמישהו יגיד... מאשר... אוקיי? וזה מאפשר לי לקדם את ההיפותזה הזאת על פני היפותזות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שיותר מתאימות לסיגנל ה... לאיי כאילו, לאקוסטי סיגנל. בסדר? בסדר. אז כל המודלי שפה היו יחסית גרועים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בגדול השתמשו בזה בעיקר לדברים כאלה, כלומר לתקן שגיאות. להגיד אוקיי, יש דברים שפשוט היינו רוצים די לפסול אותם או לתת להם עונש, כי הם דברים שמאוד לא סביר שמישהו יגיד.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ולכן כנראה השדר שאנחנו רואים הוא לא באמת מה שאנחנו חושבים שהוא, אלא הוא משהו אחר. אבל ככל שהמודלים הלכו ונהיו יותר טובים, זה התפתחות של השנים הממש אחרונות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: סדר גודל של חמש, אולי שש, שבע שנים, בטח לא יותר מזה, בעצם אנחנו רואים שאנשים מתחילים להשתמש במודל אי שפה ממש כדי לייצר טקסט
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או להשלים טקסט, זאת אומרת גם טקסטים ארוכים, לא רק לדעת שהיפותזה א' היא יותר טובה או פחות טובה מהיפותזה ב' שהיא מאוד דומה לה, אלא ממש לייצר טקסטים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שזה אומר שזה צריך לתפוס בצורה הרבה יותר טובה את הרגולריות של שפה. ובאמת אחד המודלים אני חושב הראשונים שככה הפכו את הדבר הזה ל...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הפכו את הרעיון הזה לפיזיבילי, זה מודל שנקרא ג'יפיטי 2, גם של האופן אייאיי, זה בעצם הקודם לג'יפיטי 3, שהוא המודל שעליו מבוסס הצ'אט ג'יפיטי הראשון, זה שיצא לפני...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שלא אמרנו, זה סוף 22'. אז כן, שלוש וחצי שנים כבר, אוקיי? קצת פחות משלוש וחצי שנים, משהו כזה. אז קודם קדם לו ג'יפיטי 2,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובאמת שם הם התחילו להמחיש את זה ש... הם התחילו להמחיש את זה שאפשר כבר ממש לייצר, ויש כתבה מאוד נחמדה מהניו יורקר, אתם יכולים גם להיכנס אליה אם אתם רוצים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כותב עיתונאי שהתנסה בג'י פי טי 2 וניסה בעזרתו לכתוב דברים. כמובן שהדברים השתנו מאז, כי המודלים נהיו יותר טובים, אבל בכל זאת כמה מהתובנות הן תובנות מעניינות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכמובן היום משתמשים במודלי שפה שבגדול מנסים לפתור את אותה בעיה שדיברתי עליה קודם, לחזות את המילה הבאה, משתמשים במודלי שפה כבסיס
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שבעזרתו בונים הרבה מאוד כלים כמו צ'אטבוטס, כמו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כלים לתרגום והרבה כלים אחרים שאתם מכירים. אבל יש על זה גם כמובן הרבה ביקורת, ואנשים כמו למשל גרי מרקוס, אדם ידוע בתחום, שמדבר על כך ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שבעצם אנחנו לא יכולים להסתפק במודלים ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מנסים לחזות את המילה הבאה, כי הם לא עושים פורמל ריזונינג, אין להם איזשהו מודל פורמלי של היסקים, ולכן זאת בעיה חמורה ואנחנו משלים את עצמנו ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שפשוט עוד ועוד טקסט עם מודלים יותר ויותר חזקים יספקו את הסחורה. אבל זה עוד חזון למועד, נגיע לדברים האלה בהמשך הקורס, זה רק ככה כדי לתת הקדמה ללנגוויץ' מודלים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אז זה בגדול מסכם את מה שאמרתי עכשיו. ובעצם אנחנו רואים בשנים האחרונות, מאז ג'י פי טי 2 בגדול, למרות שהיו גם כמה דברים קודם,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מאז ג'י פי טי 2 אנחנו רואים התקדמות מאוד רצינית בתחום, זה ככה עץ שלקחתי אותו פשוט כי הוא נראה יפה, אבל כמובן שההיסטוריה לא נעצרת ב2023.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מאז כבר עוד היו הסתעפויות רבות שכבר קשה לראות את כולם ואנחנו באמת רואים עניין אדיר ואנחנו רואים שחקניות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ממש כל הביג טק שהצליחו, לא כולם הצליחו, ניסו ונכשלו, אבל כל אלה שהצליחו משתתפות במשחק הזה בצורה כבדה. וגם כמה שחקנים חדשים כמו
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למשל אנטרופיק או מיסטרל, שבעצם חברות יחסית קטנות שמתחרות בגדולות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וגם כאן זה באמת הגרף הזה נפסק ב2022 אבל המגמה ממשיכה לעלות, זה מגמה לוגריתמית, כן? כאילו זה גרף לוגריתמי, כלומר אנחנו מדברים על מגמה אקספוננציאלית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מבחינת הגדלים של המודלים האלה, מספר הפרמטרים שלהם, ובהתאמה גם מספר הפעולות שנדרשות כדי לאמן אותם, כמות הדאטה שמשתמשים בה, כמות האנרגיה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וגם על זה אנחנו נדבר, זה בעצם כבר יוצר בעיות די רציניות מבחינת האפשרות לעשות לזה סקיילינג וכמה עוד ניתן
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעצם להתקדם על ידי ווד פורס, על ידי פשוט הגדלה הולכת ונשנה של המודל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אוקיי, ובאמת היום אנחנו רואים, כן, אולי עכשיו זה... אני לא יודע לכמה מכם זה מועיל, אבל בכל זאת אני אגיד את זה בקצרה. בעצם משתמשים במודלי שפה לאינסוף דברים, מלענות על שאלות,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: עובדתיות, כן? משתמשים בהן בעצם כאיזשהו סוג של נולדג' בייס, נכון? מהי בירת טורקיה או כמה גדולה צרפת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או לא יודע מתי נוסדה האוניברסיטה העברית, משתמשים בזה בשביל לתקצר דברים, לקרוא בצורה יותר אפקטיבית, משתמשים בזה לבעיות היגיון, לפתור...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בעיות להתייעץ על נושאים רפואיים, לא תמיד זה רעיון טוב, אבל זה בהחלט שימוש פופולרי וכולי וכולי
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ההיגיון הבסיסי של השימוש בלנגווץ' מודלס כיום, ששוב, אני מדגיש עם כיום, כי מודלי השפה החלשים יותר זה כנראה לא היה עובד,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: או די בוודאות לא היה עובד. זה בעצם דרך מנגנון של פרומפטינג, שוודאי אתם גם מכירים, אבל אני אגיד מאוד בקצרה. בגדול, אנחנו מנסחים את הבקשה שלנו כאיזשהו פרומפט,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אנחנו מזינים אותו למודל, המודל עצמו נשאר קבוע, כלומר הוא לא עובר אימון תוך כדי, הוא עבר איזשהו אימון כחלק מתהליך היצירה שלו, כן?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תהליך הבנייה שלו, אבל בעצם תוך כדי האינטראקציה הוא לא עובר איזשהו שינוי סטייט, מלבד איזשהו עדכון של הסטייט של השיחה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכתוצאה מזה נוצר איזשהו אאוטפוט, ובעצם הרעיון הפשוט הזה של פומפטינג, הוא מאפשר לנו אידיאלית, או לפחות הרציונל שלו, זה להחזיק איזושהי מכונה אוניברסלית
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שיודעת להתמודד עם כל הבעיות השפתיות שתזרקו עליה. כן, כבר לא... כבר לא מכונה אחת שיודעת לעשות פרט ספיץ' טאגינג, אחרת שיודעת לתקצר, שלישית שיודעת...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לענות על שאלות עובדתיות גיאוגרפיות וכולי וכולי, אלא הכול במחיר אחד, כאשר כל מה שמשתנה זה פשוט ההוראות בשפה טבעית שאתם מזינים או אותו פרומפט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מדובר, וכמובן מאז זה הלך והשתכלל ויש תחומים שיש להם פרומפט אנג'נירינג מתוחכם, זאת אומרת לפעמים הפרומפטים למודל, ניוד מסמכים מאוד ארוכים ומורכבים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שצריך קוד או לפעמים מודל שפה אחר כדי לייצר. והדברים הולכים ומסתמכים, אבל גם זה נדון רק בהמשך. בסדר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז זה ככה הקדמה ממעוף הציפור. שאלות לגבי מהו מודל שפה? מה עשו איתו בעבר? מה עושים איתו היום?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה דברים שהם יחסית מוכרים לכם או שיש כאן... כן, אוקיי, לפחות מי ש... אוקיי, סבבה, מעולה. יפה, אז בוא קצת נצלול יותר פנימה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ונשאל, בסדר, למודל שפה יש איזושהי התפלגות, הוא עומד להתפלגות, הוא מייצג התפלגות על שפה, על מחוזות. מצוין.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מה זאת ההתפלגות הזאת? זאת אומרת, מה אנחנו מנסים לשערך? אם אנחנו מנסים... נגיד הייתי מנסה לשערך את התפלגות הגבהים באוכלוסייה, אז אני אומר, אוקיי, יש אוכלוסייה, יש התפלגות אמיתית, נכון? של גבהים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמה אנשים בכל גובה נתון. ואני פשוט צריך להבין מה היא על ידי מדגם, נכון? אני לוקח דוגמאות ומנסה להבין מה היא.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אבל מה הדבר כאן שאני מנסה לשערך? מה זה בכלל ההסתברות של משפט? אז אין לזה באמת תשובה כללית, אפשר אז אולי לשאול קצת, לרדת בשאיפות ולשאול אוקיי,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז אם אני אומר אין לזה ממש מה שנקרא גראונד טרות', אין לזה ממש אמת יסודית, אז לפחות השאלה מהי התפלגות מועילה? איזה התפלגות כדאי לי ללמוד?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכאן אולי אין לנו תשובה כללית, אבל בכל זאת יש כמה הנחות שבדרך כלל מניחים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: למשל, הנחה אחת זה שאנחנו בדרך כלל רוצים שהסתברויות של משפטים שהם תקינים בשפה הנתונה, נגיד אם זה מודל עבור אנגלית, משפטים שכתובים
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שהם אולי רצף של מילים באנגלית אבל הם לא אנגלית, יקבלו הסתברות הרבה יותר נמוכה מכאלה שהם כן אנגלית. נגיד, אמור להיות הסתברות הרבה יותר גבוהה מ...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כי אחרת זה מודל שפה מאוד גרוע. אוקיי, לא רק גרמטיקליות, נגיד אולי הייתי גם רוצה שמשפטים לא הגיוניים יקבלו הסתברות מאוד נמוכה, נגיד ארטישוקס אינטימידייט זיפרס,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן או לא יודע מה, רווקים נשואים או דברים כאלה, גם יקבלו הסתברות מאוד נמוכה כי הם דברים ש...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הם לא כל כך הגיוניים ולכן אין כל כך סיכוי שמישהו ירצה לדבר עליהם. אבל אולי בהקשרים מאוד מסוימים, אבל בטח לא הסתברות גבוהה במיוחד. אבל השאלה הכללית, מה אמורה להיות ההתפלגות
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: היא כנראה שאלה שמאוד תלויה בדומיין, בקונטקסט, כן? כמו למשל אולי באיזשהו ספר ילדים שבו הגיבורים הם ארטישוקים וה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נבלים הם רוכסנים, אני לא יודע מה, אולי כן יש משמעות לדבר הזה, מי יודע, כן? בסדר. וחוץ מזה, כמובן שהיינו רוצים הרבה יותר מזה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא היינו רוצים להסתפק בדרישות המינימליות האלה, שפשוט דברים לא תקינים יקבלו הסתברות נורא נמוכה וגם דברים אולי לא מאוד פלוזבל, כן? לא מאוד פלוזבל.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מבחינת ההיגיון הסמנטי שלהם, היינו רוצים יותר מזה, היינו רוצים שהוא ייתן הסתדרות גבוהה לטקסטים קוהרנטיים וכן הלאה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר, אז כמובן ככל שאנחנו רוצים מהמודל שפה שלנו יותר, ככה אנחנו גם צריכים להקשיח את הדרישות. אם אנחנו רוצים להשתמש בו כדי לייצר טקסטים, בייחוד אם זה טקסטים רגישים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כנראה שאנחנו נדרוש דרישות יותר חמורות על ההתפלגות הזאת מאשר רק אם אנחנו רוצים נגיד להשתמש בו כמנגנון לתיקון שגיאות דקדוקיות, שפשוט אמור לתת לנו הסתדרות יותר גבוהה למשפטים תקינים דקדוקית.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הסתברות יותר גבוהה מאשר לאלה שדומים להם והם לא תקינים בגבוהות. אוקיי. עכשיו, מודלי שפה באיזשהו מובן, אם תחשבו על זה, הם בעצם בריאה קצת משונה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כי אם דיברנו קודם על המימדים השונים שיש לשפה טבעית, על זה שבעצם זה דבר שהוא מרובה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, דבר שהוא מרובה רבדים, כן, והם איכשהו פועלים ביחד, ודיברנו על כל התיחום של השפה הטבעית והקושי בלנתח אותה,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה שמודל שפה עושה זה אומר, עזבו אותי, אני לא מתעסק בכל ה... בנסות למדל בדיוק את המבנה התחבירי והמבנה הסמנטי ולהבין את ההכללות ולא יודע מה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני פשוט הולך להפוך משפט לסקלר אחד, כן? לכל משפט או כל ביטוי או כל רצף משפטים או טקסט, הולך להפוך לאיזשהו מספר טבעי בין 0 ל1,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שהוא זה שייצג אותו ביחס לאחרים, ביחס למשפטים האחרים. זה כל מה שיש לי, מספר. זה כל מה שמודל השפה נותן. מצד אחד, זאת גישה מאוד חזקה, כי היא הופכת את בעיית הלמידה לבעיית למידה מאוד קונקרטית,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: וכללית, נכון? של פשוט לשערך הסתדרות של משפט, אני כבר לא צריך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לבנות מודל אחד שעושה א', מודל שני שעושה ב', שישי שעושה ג', כל המודלים, כל מה שהם עושים זה פשוט לדעת לשערך הסתברויות של משפטים ומזה הכל נגזר.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה הרבה מהכוח של המודלים האלה, כן? אפשר לאמן אותם על הרבה מאוד דאטה, גם כי כל טקסט שקיים בעולם הוא סוג של טריינינג דאטה עבור המודל הזה, נכון? אני יכול כל פעם לחזות את המילה הבאה בהינתן הכותמות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: יחד עם זאת, זה גם החולשה שלו, בגלל שהמספר הזה לא נותן לי... בפני עצמו הוא לא אומר יותר מדי, כן? אני צריך להשוות אותו אולי לדברים אחרים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני לא יכול לצפות לאיזושהי עקביות מי יודע מה, באיך שהוא נותן את המספרים האלה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: נגיד וריאציות מאוד קלות בסטרינג עשויות להוביל ל... לא יודע, אולי תוסיפו פסיק או תמחקו נקודותיים, זה עשוי להוביל להסתברות מאוד אחרת.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לעיתים בצדק, לעיתים לא בצדק, בטח אין לי אפשרות להפריד בין הרמות השונות של הניתוח, זה הכול פשוט מספר אחד. יחד עם זאת, כנראה שזו שיטה מספיק חזקה כדי להצית את דמיונם של רבים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובעצם מה שמוביל אותנו לשאלה איך לומדים מודלי שפה. כלומר, איך אנחנו יכולים לתת הסתברויות מתקבלות על הדעת למשפטים בהינתן
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ככלל קורפוס, קורפוס של טקסטים. כלומר, הרבה מאוד, בדרך כלל הקורפוסים האלה די גדולים, מה זה אומר גדולים? אז נדבר על זה, זה תלוי כמה מתוך כמה בגדול המודל שאתם רוצים להשתמש.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ובעצם אנחנו רוצים באמצעות המשפטים האלה לשערך את המודל, כאילו את המודל שיצר את המשפטים האלה באיזשהו מובן. זאת אומרת, אנחנו הולכים, למרות שאנחנו...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: לא בדיוק יודעים מהו אותו גראון טרוס דיסטריביושן ואולי אנחנו מפקפקים, בצדק, בזה שיש איזשהו גראון טרוס דיסטריביושן נכון שממנו
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאני יכול לחשוב עליו כאוכלוסיית כל המשפטים בשפה לפי הסבירות שלהם. בכל זאת, אנחנו הולכים להניח שיש כזה ולהניח שהקורפוס שלנו נדגם מתוך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אותה התפלגות לא ידועה והם מנסים לשערך אותה, בדיוק באותה מידה שהסוקרים של מערכות הבחירות מנסים על סמך מדגם, על סמך
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאלונים וטלפונים ולא יודע מה, ביקורים וכן הלאה, לשערך מה עומדות להיות תוצאות הבחירות בבחירות הקרבות ובאות. אז אוקיי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז איך עושים את זה? אז בואו רק ממש, יש לנו כמה דקות, אז אני רק אתחיל כדי שאני חושב שהדברים יהפכו להיות קצת יותר קונקרטיים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז הדרך אולי הכי פשוטה ונאיבית זה פשוט לספור. נכון? אני אומר אוקיי, אם אני עכשיו סוקר, נכון? ואני רוצה לדעת כמה עומדים להצביע לכל מפלגה, נגיד סתם, נחזור לדוגמה של הבחירות לכנסת,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ויש לי מדגם של אנשים שנדגמו מתוך האוכלוסייה באופן אקראי נגיד, אז מה שאני יכול לעשות זה להגיד, אוקיי, ההסתדרות של... או הנתח שכל מפלגה תקבל,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: שאני אתן לה מתוך ההתפלגות, מתוך סך הקולות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה פשוט בדיוק שווה לפרופורציה בתוך המדגם של אנשים שבחרו בתוך המדגם או שדיווחו בתוך המדגם שהם עומדים להצביע לאותה מפלגה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בסדר? אז זה בעצם מה שכתוב כאן, ההסתדרות של משפט הוא פשוט מספר הפעמים שראיתי את המשפט הזה, סי זה כאילו קאונט, מספר הפעמים שראיתי את המשפט הזה בקורפוס האימון, חלקי סך כל מספר המשפטים בקורפוס האימון.
Amit Levonai: מה דעתכם על השיטה הזאת? שקודם הראית ספרסיטי על ידי פריקונסי, זה כאילו חושב ככה? כן, בדיוק. אז אם קודם דיברתי על פריקונסי ברמת המילים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: פריקונסי ברמת המשפטים זה פשוט, כן? זה נון סטארטר, כן? זאת אומרת, לא משנה כמה קורפוס שלי גדול, ברור שלא כיסיתי בצורה טובה את כל המשפטים הסבירים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואיזה כמה הולך לקבל, איזה הסתברות הולך לפי השיטה הזאת לקבל משפט שלא נתקלתי בו מילה במילה בטריינינג דאטה.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ניחוש? אפס, בדיוק. מישהו כתב לי בצ'אט, אפס עגול.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה בטח לא מה שאני רוצה לעשות, אין כאן שום הכללה, ברור שאני צריך לתת הסתברויות, לא אפס. אז המודל הזה הוא מודל לא מוצלח, אבל זו נקודת התחלה. נקודת התחלה... זאת השאלה ששאלת שוב? שהתשובה עליה הייתה אפס?
Tal Avinir: מה אתה אומר? שאלתי מה הייתה השאלה ששאלת, שהתשובה שלה, האפס. כן, השאלה אומרת, אם אני משתמש במודל הנאיבי הזה, קראתי לו המודל הטריוויאלי, כן? שמה שהוא עושה זה אומר ההסתדרות של משפט.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: זה שכיפות ההופעה היחסית שלו במדגם, כאילו בקורפוס. אוקיי? אז אם המשפט הוא לא יודע מה, אני עכשיו בזום, אז אני בודק ובקורפוס יש מיליון משפטים,
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מתוכם שניים מהם אני עכשיו בזום, אז ההסתדרות זה אחד לחצי מיליון או משהו כזה, כן? וכן הלאה. עכשיו, הבעיה היא שכל משפט שלא מופיע מילה במילה
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בקורקוס האימון נקבל אפס, נכון? אין כאן שום יכולת הכללה. בסדר? אז אפשר ללכת ולהגיד אוקיי, נכון, אז אין יכולת הכללה כי פשוט התייחסתי למשפט
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כמקשה אחת, כאיזשהו גוש אחד בלתי ניתן לפירוק, שאני סופר כמה פעמים הוא מופיע. אבל זה לא נכון. משפטים מורכבים מטוקנס, כן? מילים נגיד, אוקיי?
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אז אם המשפטים מורכבים ממילים, אני יכול אולי לנסות לשערך את ההסתברות של כל מילה בפני עצמה, אוקיי? זה אני אסבול פחות מספרסטי, כי אולי בתוך מיליון המשפטים עדיין
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: רוב המילים יופיעו, אוקיי? או אולי אפילו כל המילים שמופיעות במשפט הזה יופיעו, אוקיי? ואז אני אוכל לשערך את ההסתברויות שלהם, הם לא יהיו אפס.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ואני אכפיל את ההסתברויות. זו תהיה ההסתברות של משפט. אוקיי? אז הדבר הזה בהחלט מכליל, נכון? כי גם אם לא הופיע לי, גם אם לא הופיע לי המשפט
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: אני בזום בקורפוס, אם מספיק שיופיע איים, יופיע און ויופיע זום, כדי שהמשפט הזה יקבל הסתברות לא אפס, נכון? גם אם אף פעם לא הופיעו...
Tal Avinir: ביחד במשפט שכולל אך ורק את שלושתם. מה הבעיה עם המודל הזה? שאולי שהמשפטים שמכילים את אותן מילים בסדר הפוך יקבלו את אותה הסתברות?
נעמה אבן עוז: נגיד למשל בסדר הפוך, נכון? זהו, עכשיו זה בא על חשבון הקריאות של המשפט, או על כמה שהוא הגיוני. נכון. אוקיי, למשל, מה יהיה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: מה יהיה המשפט הסביר ביותר לפי המודל הזה באורך שלוש? מה דעתכם? אולי ה...
Agam Hershko: כן, מישהו התחיל לענות? אולי השלוש מילים הראשונות או המילה הראשונה שלוש פעמים? המילה...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: כן, אז בוא נגיד שהמילה הכי סבירה בשפה, כלומר הכי נפוצה בשפה, היא באנגלית נגיד זה. כן, זה בדרך כלל מה שקורה. אז מה המשפט הכי סביר בין שלוש מילים? דה, דה, בדיוק.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בדיוק. זה יהיה זה, זה, לא סביר שזה... זה לא משפט טוב, ברור. כאילו, אז מה שהמודל הזה, הוא באיזשהו מובן מניח הנחות מקלות מדי.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: הוא מניח אי תלות בין הטוקנס, בעוד שזה הניח שזה פשוט, כן, אטומי, כן? שהמשפט הוא אטומי ואין לו שום חלקים שאני יכול לייחס להם הסתברות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בפני עצמם. אנחנו נצטרך למצוא, וזה כבר נעשה אחרי פסח, נצטרך לנסות למצוא מודלים שימצאו איזשהו סוויט ספוט בין שני הדברים.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: ומשם נמשיך. אז אני רואה שלא הגענו כל כך לחומר הטכני, אז אני חושב שנפרסם באמת את התרגיל כבר אחרי פסח, אבל זה בסדר, נסתדר. אז...
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: בקיצור, נאחל לכם ימים טובים, חג שמח, ונקווה להתראות בקמפוס אחרי החג. תודה רבה. תודה רבה, יום טוב. תודה רבה, להתראות.
עמרי عُومري Omri Abend: תודה רבה. תודה. אה, ראיתי גם עכשיו ש... ראיתי שכתבת ש... כן, אני יודע. ביקשתי מהם להחליף. כן, תודה. סבבה. ביי, תודה.